bonjour à garder pour ce nouvel épisode
de probablement avec célia grues sont
daniel docteur en sciences de
l'information et de la communication co
fondatrice de hackers péï ce qui est
cofondatrice récente de drissa l'éthique
bonjour si là comment ça va bonjour ça
va très bien quoi
très bien est ce que tu vas commencer
par présenter un petit peu ton parcours
oui bien sûr donc pour faire court mon
parcours je viens de bio à la base j'ai
fait des études de biologie je me suis
ensuite spécialisé en sciences
cognitives
j'ai fait un master neuroscience
cognitive et comportementale à
l'université pierre et marie curie et en
même temps j'ai été admis sur diploma de
la nes l'école normale supérieure où
j'ai pu suivre différents cours variés
en sciences cognitives no 6 sur tout un
parcours art science par exemple et
ensuite j'ai décidé après mon master de
ne pas faire de pez et de faire une
formation supplémentaire en
communication scientifique qui est une
marque que j'ai fait en cours du soir au
cnam et j'ai commencé à travailler en
tant que community manager d'un réseau
social scientifique
voilà et ensuite j'ai fait différents
projets j'ai créé un cure pièce dit et
j'ai travaillé dans un sens de santé
publique où j'ai été en charge des
mouches donc de lancer les mots qu à
l'époque donc il ya quatre ans et en
parallèle j'ai commencé une thèse tout
en travaillant en donc ô mon école
doctorale c'était le prix centre de
recherche interdisciplinaire et j'ai
fait ma thèse
entre un laboratoire sciences sociales à
l'université de technologie de compiègne
et l'université laval au québec et je
viens de finir ma thèse en novembre
dernier
voilà pour mon parcours ok doutes quant
aux tests c'est tu as passé la moitié de
trop
au québec et le moitié alors pas pas
vraiment j'ai surtout été à paris
puisque je travaillais mais j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir mon employeur qui m'a
laissé faire deux sessions une première
un semestre à l'université laval donc
j'ai pu suivre les premiers les cours de
première année au québec ce qui a été
vraiment super pour m'aider à cadrer ma
thèse est mon sujet et ensuite j'ai pu
refaire un stage de recherche à l'uqam
pendant trois mois donc j'ai vraiment eu
la chance que mon employeur a permis que
d'arranger mon temps de travail pour
pour me permettre de battue continue ma
recherche de trésors au québec mais oui
j'ai beaucoup a beaucoup aimé j'ai connu
l'hiver voilà donc sur le campus de
l'université laval ce qu'ils étaient
c'est toujours très sympa parce qu'il ya
plein aussi d'étudiants quand on vit
dans sur le campus internationaux donc
c'est vraiment vraiment une super
ambiance aussi beaucoup beaucoup de
travail
d'être tout le temps dans la
bibliothèque pour avancer donc c'était
voilà dans le cocon d'hiver au québec
et puis le stage aussi l'été à montréal
était très très agréable j'ai découvert
plein de choses
voilà il ya un côté très très
entrepreneurs aussi sociale qui était
qui était présent et j'ai beaucoup et si
aimé découvrir comment la recherche
était pensée là bas et la différence par
rapport à la france
donc voila c'était de très bons
souvenirs
c'est cauet différence avec la france je
pense qu'il ya ba ça sera un long sujet
sur les différences culturelles et là on
rentre aussi un peu sur ce qui me
passionne au niveau recherche les
terrains de recherche qui sont qui sont
ceux de comprendre comment la recherche
fait aujourd'hui qu'est ce que c'est que
la science qu'elles sont aussi les
différences culturelles qui font qu'on
pense la science différemment par
exemple je te disais tout à l'heure j'ai
beaucoup apprécié les cours en première
année parce que la balle
le doctorat est vraiment structuré
on voit passer une première année à
avoir deux examens importants pour
construire son projet de recherche
donc c'est vraiment en sciences sociales
en tout cas en sciences humaines et
sociales
on est pour moi on est vraiment pris par
la main et honteux on te jette pas dans
le grand bain tant que tu a peint un
projet bien bien le cadrer ou pas
répondu déjà des questions de
problématiques de méthodologie et autres
donc ça c'est une différence par exemple
avec la france et j'ai vraiment eu
beaucoup de chance d'avoir ce soutien là
par exemple il y avait un groupe que
j'adorais c'était le fait qu'on se
mettait en petits groupes et on
présentait notre projet de recherche aux
autres doctorants et c'était les
doctorants qui nous faisait des retours
et il y avait juste un professeur qui
étaient là comme comme mentor au final
mais c'est pas lui qui donnait son avis
et c'était beaucoup plus fluide et
horizontale et d'avoir l'avis d'autres
doctorants finalement n'était au même
niveau et c'est ça aussi que je vois
dans le rapport c'est peut-être moins un
rapport de tu as le professeur d'un côté
et tu as les doctorants de l'autre et
les rapports très hiérarchique et en
termes de des changes
beaucoup plus de liberté paroles de
discussion que j'ai que j'ai beaucoup
apprécié et du couvent en parlant de
torchères chose qui cloche chez le
docteur alors ma thèse si tu veux le
titre c'est numérique et régime français
des savoirs en action l'open en sciences
et le cas de la consultation république
numérique entre parenthèses 2015 donc
voilà toujours les titres de deux thèses
un peu à rallonge mais pour faire court
on atteste ça c'est venu d'une
interrogation sur sur quelle
signification on met derrière le terme
openskies le plus tôt open en sciences
parce qu'il ya le terme open access open
data et c'est en rentrant dans un cas
précis de
flea de dialogue pour définir ce que
c'est que l'open sayoud c'est plutôt
l'open access dans le cas de la
consultation est plus méric voir
finalement les différentes conceptions
qu'on a actuellement de la science du
numérique et que tout dans le domaine
des ce qu'on appelle les sts donc
saillants de cette technologie citadis
l'étude des sciences et technologies
traduction française par l'étude des
sciences technologie et société
le but ça a été vraiment de comprendre
les transformations notre régime des
serveurs actuellement c'est à dire
comment la science la production de
savoirs
elle s'intègre dans un système
économique dans un cadre culturel aussi
mais aussi dans un certain d imaginaire
de ce que devrait être la science
aujourd'hui des idéaux et c'est ça qu'on
connaisse ou vocable de science mais
finalement c'est en sts et en histoire
des sciences on parle de régime des
savoirs voilà donc je me suis appuyé sur
ce concept là pour pour mes recherches
du coup si je crois mais ya pas mal de
divergences sur ce qu'on entend par
openskies je prendrai quelles sont les
différentes différents camps du oui
alors bien sûr que ça reste moi j'ai
pris un et c'est ça qui est intéressant
de comprendre aussi c'est que je me suis
vraiment basé sur de la recherche
qualitative
donc j'ai pris un terrain d'étude bien
précis qui est celui de la consultation
république numérique donc pour juste
expliqué c'est en 2015 il ya eu un
projet de loi qui s'appelle projet doit
république numérique qui était lancé
pour réguler un peu tout ce qui est
l'économie autour des données du
numérique qui avait différents volets
dans ce projet de loi et il ya une phase
consultative donc la consultation
république numérique qui a été lancée et
où il y avait une plate forme est sûre
cette plateforme il y avait un premier
un pré-projet de loi qui était proposé
avec différents articles et pour chaque
article était possible de voter pour
contrôler tg il était aussi possible de
commenter
l'article de loi mais ce qui était
intéressant il était aussi possible de
proposer une autre version du projet de
loi ce qu'on appelle un amendement et ça
c'est important à comprendre parce que
finalement il ya plein de personnes
qu'on proposait d'autres versions du
d'un article que j'ai étudié qu est l
article sur le libre accès aux
publications scientifiques et là dessus
c'est vraiment là dessus je me suis basé
mais ce que donc vraiment pourquoi je
dis moi ça a été vraiment un cas d'étude
donc ce que j'amène dans mon analyse
c'est l'analyse que j'ai faite ce cas
d'étude là et le but c'est que ça puisse
servir peut-être à d'autres sur d'autres
cas d'étude voir si la grille d'analysé
que j'amène des différentes conceptions
de l'open sky ans correspond à d'autres
terrains d'autres cas d'étude par la
suite donc voilà j'ai pas vocation à
dire c'est comme ça en général c'est pas
le but de ma recherche qualitative mais
c'est dur voilà j'essaye de dans le
petit domaine que j'ai étudié d'apporter
une grille d'analysé une clé de lecture
en espérant qu'elle puisse servir
puisque qu'elles puissent être prises
par d'autres peut être modifié mais
quelle qu'elles peuvent finalement
apporté de l'eau au moulin
donc ça c'était un point qui est
important pour moi de faire comprendre
aussi sur cette différence entre plus
des cantons vient de stm donc sciences
techniques médecine voilà des critères
aussi ce qu'on appelle un paradigme de
recherche qui est un peu différent que
dans la recherche quantitative
donc ça c'est important pour moi de de
mettre en avant déjà en préliminaires
posées ça et maintenant pour répondre à
ta question en termes de donc j'ai
vraiment essayé de comprendre ce que
l'open signifiait pour pour différentes
personnes et pour faire court
j'ai regardé ce que certaines personnes
pourquoi des personnes étaient contrôle
open contre l'ouverture des
connaissances et surtout contre la passe
que l'article 9 donc sur le libre accès
c'était vraiment un article qui donnait
la possibilité à tout un chacun d'avoir
accès en ligne à des publications
scientifiques
quand elles étaient payés pour moitié
par la recherche publique
donc c'est ça le libre-accès c'est
important de comprendre ce combat
derrière parce que actuellement si tu
veux accéder à des articles
scientifiques
tu dois payer je sais pas si toi tu as
ça a été ton cas pendant ta ta ta thèse
ou tes recherches domine souvent il faut
payer des abonnements
en tout cas c'est le ponton universités
qui qui prend c'est en charge du rct
pour voilà c'est ça mais derrière et
c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu ce mouvement
de l'open access qui s'est développée
avec le finalement le début de
l'internet et puis du web c'est de dire
mais maintenant publier ça coûte ça
coûte moins cher et pourquoi est-ce
qu'on peut pas mettre librement comme ça
nos publications scientifiques et ça
fait un bouleversement énorme dans le
monde de la recherche est finalement moi
c'est ça qui a étudié et au niveau point
de vue j'ai étudié aussi bien des points
de vue de ceux qui étaient contre qui
disaient d'accord
l'open access c'est bien mais ça a quand
même un coût non de on est contre et ça
a été beaucoup le cas de petits éditeurs
de petites maisons d'édition en shs qui
se sont affirmés et qui ont qui leur
point de vue et c'est intéressant de
voir parce que moi c'est vraiment ce que
j'essaie de faire c'est pas prendre
parti alors que j'ai mon propre point de
vue celle ci est de voir tous les
différents points de vue et pas les
juger il est par exemple ceux qui
viennent de l'édition en sciences
humaines et sociales
leur point de vue c'est dire on a une
culture de l'édition de publication des
chercheurs en sciences humaines sciences
humaines et sociales c'est plutôt ce
qu'on appelle des monographies des
libres les bas notre modèle économique
il va pas pouvoir suivre parce qu'il ya
tout un accompagnement d'édition pour
faire de l'édition de bonne qualité sert
à ça nécessite du temps que ses dégoûts
aussi donc tous à nyon pour faire ce
basculement vers l'open access on a
besoin d'un suivi on a besoin d'une aide
est aussi un autre point de vue c'est
celui de dire que
qui va garantir la qualité du travail
fait si le rôle de l'éditeur aussi n'est
pas là mais plus d'un rôle d'éditeur qui
va organiser et co-organisé tout ce qui
est de la revue par les pairs donc voilà
est aussi autre point de ces éditeurs
qui est intéressant plus d'un point de
vue d'un de la figure du chercheur en
tant qu en sciences humaines et sociales
plus comme un intellectuel qui a besoin
de son indépendance et que l'éditeur par
le contrat qu'il a avec ce chercheur la
lui garantit aussi une indépendance de
ce qu'il va pouvoir dire et de ce qui va
pouvoir publier et là ce qui est
intéressant pour faire un lien avec ce
que je te disais du régime des savoirs
ou tout le régime des savoirs c'est est
une arête c'est un moment c'est pâques
les rincer en sens inverse j'amène
beaucoup de notions mais et c'est dans
le régime de savoir c'est aussi à qu'on
rattache la science et les lettres les
sciences et lettres et à des idéaux et
là ce qui était très fort dans leur
discours
c'est celui des lumières c'est à dire le
chercheur en tant que qu'intellectuel
qui apportent des connaissances mais qui
aussi besoin d'avoir une autonomie
d'indépendance donc ce qui mettait
beaucoup en avant c'est ce rapport entre
l'éditeur et le chercheur qui permettent
de garantir l'indépendance aussi du
chercheur et le rayonnement des savoirs
donc ça c'était un des premiers points
de vue que j'ai mis en avant l'autre
point de vue qui va peut-être plus te
parler parce qu'il est plus proche du de
la figure du chercheur actuellement par
exemple moi toi qui dit bart ou même le
citoyen de dire voilà la recherche
allait payer beaucoup par là on est dans
la recherche publique mais travaille son
père est payé par par l'état qui me paye
en tant que chercheur en plus je fais
tout le travail souvent quand je vais
publier comment ça fonctionne
j'ai publié dans une revue donc par
exemple je suis un chercheur en biologie
je veux publier dans un dans un journal
par exemple
j'essaye de devises et d'aider des
journaux à x factor
en fait c'est à dire qu'il est très
reconnu dans ma discipline
donc dans nature ou science et pour ça
je vais proposer un article et et il va
avoir un comité qui sont mes pairs donc
d'autres chercheurs qui vont qui vont re
lire un article c'est ce qu'on appelle
tout processus de peer review pour dire
si mon article est valide sans
scientifiquement ou pas et faire des
commentaires et autres
il ya donc tout ce processus et ce
processus finalement les chercheurs ils
le font bénévolement ils sont pas payés
pour faire ce qu'on appelle la revue par
les pairs donc le point de vue du
chercheur s'il se dire voilà moi je
travaille je fais ce travail aussi
bénévolement de revue par les pairs et
je publiais après dans des 10 journaux
et finalement ce que je publiais ce que
je fait bénévolement et ce qui est payé
finalement par la recherche publique et
basses et des éditeurs qui sont souvent
on a derrière sail nature des gros
éditeurs des multinationales qui
détiennent ces journaux l'as et c'est
pas normal finalement eux c'est du ford
profite et c'est pas normal qu'ils qui
se font finalement des sous sur les
savoirs donc un point très important
pour ceux qui sont pour le libre accès
c'est de dire que on a les moyens avec
ce passage au numérique
finalement de se réapproprier nous
savoir
parce qu'on peut développer soit des
journaux on peut au final on a les
moyens avec des seins structure de
redévelopper d'aider des journaux des
revues pour pouvoir publier
donc c'est pas normal qu'on soit encore
pieds et mains liés à ces gros éditeurs
donc là le but c'est comment est ce qu
ont rétabli un équilibre maintenant dans
un monde qui est numérique entre ces
gros éditeurs qui font du profit ou la
balance avait plus équilibré d'un point
de vue économique
et ça c'est un point de vue très
important et qui structurent finalement
finalement les instituts de recherche
aujourd'hui où les financeurs de la
recherche publique par exemple l'europe
qui est un très grand financeurs ou
d'autres
qui disent bon bah là il faut qu'on voit
c'est un peu un jeu de voilà on reprend
du pouvoir sur sur des abus avec des
éditeurs des gros des oligopoles des
grandes multinationales
donc ça c'est un point de vue qui est
très important et qui se structure
autour de la science ouverte aujourd'hui
institutionnelle d'une recherche
réapproprier donc ça c'est quelque chose
que tu rapport s'est passé le prix de
ces revues sur ce coup de vent entre
très cher je suis j'ai pas du tout les
prisons peut-être mes cheveux studen non
j'ai pas les prix je veux pas alors il
ya plein de jeux pour être maître en si
tu veux te donner les liens après il ya
beaucoup de blogs qui va par exemple je
crois qu'il ya un blog en français qui
s'appelle science comme une science
ouverte que j'avais analysé qui par
exemple se positionne et qui redonne
aussi des chiffres par rapport à elle et
vire qu'il ya un gros éditeur donc il ya
tout un rangement ainsi très fort dans
la recherche
alors plutôt dans les disciplines qui
sont concernés en physique en biologie
où il ya cette idée de boycott elsevier
c'est à dire plus vouloir publier dans
ce petit heures parce que c'est tuer
c'est injuste c'est une situation
injuste alors je veux pas te dire de
bêtises mais mme ida beaucoup beaucoup
aussi de pourparlers parce que comment
sa structure par exemple en france il ya
un consortium d'acteurs qui avec des
bibliothécaires des universités qui va
négocier les prix avec les éditeurs et
pour peser un peu donc là-dessus cdd
sujet très délicat
les chiffres aussi sont pas forcément
donné mais tu jeu peu près te pointer
sur un ensemble de deux sites parce
qu'il ya vraiment des chercheurs des
personnes qui se sont spécialisées sur
sur cette partie là pour te donner pour
que tu es des chiffres précis sur par
exemple combien ça coûte de s'abonner à
elle respire pour une université
il ya un chiffre six qui est super qui
reprend tout
les datas dans le mouvement d'open data
pour faire des visualisations combien
par exemple la france a dépensé en
termes d'abonnements de publications
scientifiques
aujourd'hui il ya un super site je te
retrouverai le lien le pour donner ces
informations là qui permet de vraiment
de d'avoir une vision de cette quantité
d'argent qui est dépensé pour pouvoir
payer des abonnements à des grands
écrans des éditeurs qui dure de l'ordre
de grandeur des millions d'années
passées c'est plutôt je pense que
millions mais ça dépend des instituts si
tu as aidé millions en france oui je
pense que c'est des millions et après si
tu veux plus à une échelle individuelle
par exemple moi pour l'instant je n'ai
plus d'affiliation g1 finir ma thèse
donc je me suis étudiante et je me
retrouve dans le cas et ça arrive à
beaucoup de personnes et c'est moi c'est
un quart en viendra peut-être pas autour
de l'accueil pied jeudi de dire quand tu
n'es plus dans le secteur académique ou
même si le cas de petites entreprises si
tu veux accéder en article c'est à peu
près entre un article 40 $ par exemple
donc voilà après c'est rare que des
personnes vont payer seulement pour un
article
mais aimer là dessus tu as il ya plein
de plein de contenus de vulgarisation de
médiation sur sur la partie open access
pourquoi l'open access pourquoi si
nécessaire et où cette cette idée de
deux coups mais aussi ça c'est un autre
point de vue un autre argument très fort
qui a amené c'est à dire que moi en tant
que citoyen et c'est un cétacé ça qui
était intéressante sur la consultation
république nous munich c'est qu'on a eu
aussi des entre guillemets des citoyens
qui se sont exprimés et qui ont dit bah
voila moi je ne fais pas partie de la
recherche
et c'est pas normal que parce que je
paye c'est mes infos finalement si la
recherche publique que je ne puisse pas
accéder à ce et ses connaissances et ses
articles donc ça c'était un autre
argument très fort et que moi aussi j'ai
entre guillemets en disant bas
actuellement je veux continuer à avancer
sur des projets de recherche la plus en
sciences cognitives sur les et inventif
y ait de conscience comment j'accède à
ces articles là donc après il ya
d'autres solutions c'est à dire de façon
pratique tu peux accéder avec tout ce
qui s'est mise en place au niveau des
archives ouvertes
c'est à dire que tu peux publier un
article dans une grande revue mais
souvent est ce assez peu connu des
chercheurs ici pour ça que si tout n'est
une éducation à faire retrouver ses
lettres sciences ouvert c'est que tu as
droit souvent de pouvoir publier la
version même revue par les pairs n'est
pas la version éditeurs une version la
dernière version mais sans la mise en
page souvent tu as droit de la publier
et avec cet article avec cette loi pour
vendre et or république munich il ya un
article qui est passé qui s'appelle
l'article 30 maintenant et qui donne le
droit à tout chercheur qui a publié
après un temps d'embargo c'est à dire
après un temps de rétention de six mois
dans les stm ou de 12 mois dans les shs
tout chercheur si finalement ces
publications ont été financés pour
moitié par des recherches par l'argent
public
il a le droit de le mettre en ligne
quand même si ça l'éditeur n'est pas
d'accord donc après six mois ou 12 mois
a le droit de mettre ton article
et ça c'est un droit c'est à dire que
c'est ça qui est intéressant de
comprendre c'est que ce n'est pas une
obligation du chercheur et ça c'était un
argumentaire de certains citoyens qui
étaient extrêmes qui disait aux deux
personnes c'est pas normal
le chercheur il devrait avoir
l'obligation de publier ses articles
là c'est pas le cas mais c'est un droit
qui était donné après 6 mois et 12 mois
mais souvent c'est le cas c'est à dire
que de plus en plus si tu est financé
par un projet européen ou même de plus
par l'anr agence nationale de la
recherche
ils vont demander des départs quand tu
vas être financier que tu es publication
sur en open access même façon qu'une
parce qu'il ya vraiment cette conscience
de d'ouvrir les savoirs à à la société
de là c'est quelque chose qui a prononcé
des rations assez cool parce qu'après il
ya donc t'as pas beaucoup de côtés
injustice assez d'argent public et
seulement ici le côté efficacité de la
recherche en tant que chercheur souvent
on préfère être luxueux pas être
forcément si la tendance à préférer
avoir les accès des publications
passionnant et cible quitte à y laisser
quelques nouvelles tours donc c'est ça
et et par rapport à cette notion
d'efficacité c'est ça qui est très
intéressant c'est qu'il ya une
efficacité à la fois d'un point de vue
institutionnel c'est à dire que là c'est
cette idée de bon pas seulement les
articles maintenant un grand sujet
actuellement c'est les datas c'est
l'ouverture des données qui servent à
faire la recherche par exemple un
domaine que je connais bien j'avais fait
un mook là dessus sur et j'avais
interviewé des personnes sur tout ce qui
est sciences numériques et sciences du
vivant et questionner finalement toute
ouverture du processus de la recherche
et je te donne un exemple très concret
tu fais de l'imagerie médicale donc
l'imagerie ça coûte si tu fais de l'irm
ça coûte ça coûte cher et cetera on sait
aussi qu'en sciences voilà quand un
petit échantillon
ça fonctionne pas forcément donc tu vas
avoir des plus gros échantillons est
donc un point important là encore des
chercheurs mais aussi de ceux des
financeurs c'est de dire non finance des
recherches ou la collecte de données va
coûter cher et il est important que ces
données soient mises à disposition pour
que d'autres chercheurs puise aussi s'en
servir
et il ya énormément d'un jeu autour de
là on rentre vraiment non plus seulement
l'open access mais l'open science la
science ouverte c'est comment on
organise aussi toute ouverture du
processus de la recherche de la dir de
d'un appel à financement c'était en même
temps
projet de recherche même si que tu as ta
pas encore financé il peut être ouvert
pour rappel à d'autres personnes mais
aussi toute cette collecte des données
et ça c'est important pour que d'autres
puissent travailler sur ces données mais
qui demande un effort énorme derrière
très technique aussi de management de
gestion de ses données de structuration
de ces données de 2 comment est-ce que
tu structure une base de données tout ce
qui est question des métadonnées aussi
donc ça c'est quelque chose on est en
plein dedans actuellement est-ce que
c'est se mettre d'accord sur des normes
sur des identifiants pour faciliter
finalement tout ce processus de
recherche pour une plus grande alors
efficacité donc aussi pour pour pour les
instituts les financeurs voilà pour
perdre autant d'argent
donc on a ce côté aussi efficacité
économique qui est très présent
et là je reviendrai peut-être mais
d'être dans un système de la recherche à
un système on n'appelle ni au libéral
c'est à dire un système productiviste
qui doit fonctionner ou mais aussi de la
compétitivité
par exemple en europe on essaye d'avoir
la la compétitivité mais aussi de la
cooptation entre pays pour faire des
projets à l'échelle européenne mais on
est dans ce système aussi très lourd
économique il ya peu choo aussi donné
mais il faut perdre mon argent et il ya
aussi 7.7 au point de vue qui disait
c'est une efficacité aussi pour en tant
que chercheur c'est à dire que quand on
est chercheur on a une question on veut
pouvoir y répondre
donc on veut pouvoir accéder aux
publications scientifiques mais aussi un
point de vue intéressant et ça c'est
c'est un point en lien avec l'open
saillantes si un autre argumentaire qui
est finalement celui qu'on porte depuis
longtemps avec actu repique j'ai appelé
dans ma tête l'idée au pana aubaine
scientist c'est ce qu'ils disent
moi je veux plus croire entre guillemets
croire et ça je sais que c'est un voilà
qu'est ce qu'on croit ou pas mais je
veux plus seulement avoir accès aux
résultats
que je veux c'est que maintenant qu'on
est dans une science qui est ni de plus
en plus une bataille ans donc liée aux
données autres moi ce que je veux c'est
avoir accès aux publications
scientifiques en résultat mais je veux
pouvoir retracer tout le processus de la
recherche
donc à tous est en jeu et qu'on trouve
dans d'autres domaines par exemple au
tour de l'open pas seulement en science
cette idée de transparence bon après on
peut se questionner en sciences humaines
et sociales en ski estienne beaucoup
qu'est ce que c'est que la transparence
parce qu'une transparence est possible
là vraiment mais il ya cette idée de je
veux pouvoir accéder aux données entre
guillemets brut parce que pareil en
rester là si tu veux on déconstruit tout
donc pour nous d'être données brutes ça
n'existe pas il ya toujours quelqu'un
qui a fait un travail derrière mais on
veut avoir accès aux données
on veut avoir accès au script qu'il a
qui sont que finalement le chercheur
utilisent et donc accéder au script là
on arrive aussi à des questions dans une
vision de l'open scientist avoir accès à
des logiciels qui sont frits et open
source
parce que sinon ça sert à rien si
j'utilise un logiciel propriétaire je
pas pouvoir avec ma machine finalement
réouvrir les scripts de regarder donc il
ya toute cette dimension si logiciels
libres et ouverts et formats ouverts dès
des publications des scripts est très
important pour que ça puisse être
finalement fluide et pouvoir reproduire
finalement des scripts regarder et voir
ce qui a été fait 6 et reproductive ou
pas donc il ya tout cet enjeu de
reproductibilité qui est très important
et qui est un enjeu très important ni
derrière l'open saillantes et c'est pour
ça que ça a été un des argumentaires des
chercheurs lors de la consultation chez
que j'ai étudié aussi qui est celle de
cette vision l'accès aux articles c'est
bien mais c'est pas suffisant
s'il faut c'est avoir accès au si
à tous les objets de la recherche
actuellement les skritts les datas et
autres et ça c'est un point important et
qui a amené aussi des discussions sur
tout ce qu'on appelle le texte et
datamining
c'est à dire la fouille de textes et de
données que les chercheurs ont le droit
de pouvoir faire de la fouille de
données actuellement tu te prends un
exemple très simple quand tu travailles
en sciant tome et rita des milliers d du
travail sur des bases de données et tu
veux faire une méta analyse et que tu
veux regarder pas seulement les titres
des mets tu veut fouiller dans les
textes qu voir ce qui est dit avec même
des méthodes de machine learning et
autres pour avoir une vision un peu
dedans une discipline qu'est ce qui est
dit comment s'est dit est haute les
résultats ça nécessite d'accéder aux
publications scientifiques et pour
l'instant c'est pas possible parce qu'il
faut payer si en plus ces bases de
données elles appartiennent à des
éditeurs dont clara tube tu vois tu
retrouves le lien entre eux à qui
appartiennent ces bases de données
d'articles ou aussi dans le sur le web
l'un sciences humaines et sociales on
utilise beaucoup de données du web qui
sont des données non structurées et
autres à qui appartiennent ces données
est ce qu'on a le droit quand on est
chercheur d'avoir une exception par
exemple à la propriété des données pour
pouvoir faire de la fouille de données
où tu vois dans le cas de deux projets
de santé aussi s'il ya des données qui
viennent de jeu c'est pas de facebook de
twitter ou de blogs ou autres
pour l'instant ces données elles
appartiennent à ces plates formes là
donc c'est il ya une exception à mettre
pour avoir le droit de fouiller ses
textes et ses données donc ça c'est un
énorme enjeu actuellement et qui est pas
réglée et qui montre aussi que
actuellement les enjeux pour comprendre
l'open saillantes
c'est des enjeux économiques très forte
mais des enjeux juridiques aussi très
fort et ils vendent sur le
questionnement de la propriété
intellectuelle du droit d'auteur du
droit des bases de données et qui sont
passionnants mais qui sont on en discute
à l'échelle français à l'échelle
européen et cd
la détention des discussions des
expérimentations qui sont faites et
c'est ça qui est chouette parce que
c'est émouvant aussi leur juste redire
sur la consultation du numérique qu'il y
avait beaucoup du vol qui était
participants de cette modification
alors moi je me suis surtout intéressé à
l'article donc neuf quand il disait le
libre accès aux publications
scientifiques
mais plus globalement il y avait donc
pour l'article 9 ceux qui se sont
exprimés et dans ma tête j'ai étudié
j'ai aussi essayé de en sciences
humaines et sociales
il ya toute la question de comment
est-ce qu'on intègre des méthodes
numériques dans une recherche
qualitative
donc moi ce que j'ai fait grâce à la
conscience de quatrebarbes qu'il avait
qui je travaille on a pu faire une
cartographie finalement des similarités
de vote qui votent par et culture un
trio cet article est de voir un peu
qu'ils avaient participé donc j'ai
essayé si tu veux d'utilisation à des
recherches qualitatives et à la fois une
cartographie pour un peu voir là l'image
globale de faire des zooms sur quelques
acteurs sachant comment après j'ai
étudié les discours l'argument clair et
pas les personnes je me suis distancier
des personnes parce que c'est aussi je
voulais pas affronter du doigt telle
personne mais montrer aussi que en
fonction des situations
une même personne peut utiliser
différents argumentaire en fonction de
qui à l'en face et où elle se situe donc
voilà je me suis mais pour te dire
globalement les acteurs qu'on a qui se
sont exprimés il ya l'idée de la
personne qui en dehors de la recherche
qui s'intéressent à ces sujets là donc
entre guillemets le citoyen est à la
fois des chercheurs qui se sont exprimés
donc des chercheurs très engagé dans
l'open l'eau pétillante l'open access
plus en stm donc sciences t'es grighine
et chine mais aussi en shs qui se sont
exprimés avec des points de vue aussi
parfois différentes celui que je te
disais tout à l'heure un peu de l'open
scientiste qui dit c'est pas suffisante
donne accès aux articles fawkes m6 aux
données etc
c'était personnes restées m
monsieur en shs après il y avait toute
la partie entre institutionnels
c'est à dire des personnes qui oeuvrent
actuellement en france parce que ça a
été beaucoup de français puisque c'était
comme je disais citer un cas d'étude
français donc beaucoup de personnes en
france qui travaille par exemple sur les
archives ouvertes en france il ya une
archives ouvertes qui s'appelle al
quelles archives ouvertes nationale et
beaucoup de personnes se sont exprimées
voilà des archives ouvertes mais aussi
en shs de d'initiative publique
nationale pour créer d une plate-forme
les infrastructures de publication en
sciences humaines et sociales dont deux
qui se sont exprimés qui propose des
blogs mais aussi une plate forme de deux
revues en ligne dont ils se sont
exprimés ya eu aussi plus des acteurs
notamment un groupe pour qui s'appelle
le groupement français des industriels
de l'information qui est plutôt un
regroupement d'acteurs de l'information
scientifique et technique qui qui
participent aux décisions qui organise
aussi le rapport entre ce que je te
disais la recherche publique les acteurs
publics et les éditeurs privés qui se
sont exprimés donc plus des groupes de
travail de conseil sur ces questions là
il ya aussi des éditeurs privés mais
plus plus dans le cas français ça a été
beaucoup tourné sciences humaines et
sociales le cas silence humaines et
sociales et rencontres soit on a eu
beaucoup moins en tout cas sur la place
publique numérique accès aux discours et
aux six sûrement au aux éléments de
discours de des éditeurs privés
internationaux anglais qui peut-être se
sont exprimés c'est ça qui est
intéressant
plus directement auprès du gouvernement
mais dans des cercles qui sont privées
et non pas sur la sphère publique
voilà et après ce qui était intérêts
ça aussi c'est qu'on a eu beaucoup de
personnes dans cette baisse dans cet
engagement plus global autour du
logiciel libre et open source et de ce
qu'on appelle actuellement des communs
donc c'est à dire d'une vision est que
et match et j'étudie beaucoup déçu
certes idée qu'il faut sortir de cette
dichotomie un peu pris des publics et
que les savoirs ce sont des communs des
communs numérique et qu'il s'agit de
gérer ensemble en mettant des règles
avec différents acteurs créer un
écosystème juste avec des règles justes
de gouvernance de ces communs et qui
sortent de cette vision privé-public la
recherche publique d'un côté et des
acteurs privés de l'autre qui veulent
que faire du profit donc il ya eu
beaucoup de personnes autour des communs
qui se sont exprimés et du logiciel
libre aussi alors beaucoup peut-être pas
beaucoup mais en tout cas ils se sont
aussi exprimés sur le sujet dès cette
idée de savoir libre de savoir en commun
mais ils se sont aussi exprimés c'est
des acteurs qui étaient très présents
sur d'autres articles
par exemple il ya eu un article qui
était sûr sur les communs qui a disparu
qui est l article 8 si je me trompe ri
qui après disparu dans la loi ou
d'autres personnes engagées dans les
mouvements par exemple de l'open data
plus généralement c'est à dire l'accès
aux données publiques
du gouvernement ou où par exemple les
données météorologiques ou d'autres
choses ou les données de financement
plus générale donc finalement l'open
saillantes s'il faut comprendre que
c'est englobé dans un mouvement plus
large d'open society is open government
d'open data et ces acteurs là se sont
aussi exprimés sur ce sujet là donc
voilà pour moi ce fut grâce genre partie
de leurs cheveux choix leur show
forcément puisque une dizaine
c'est ça et j'ai étudié tout ça si tu
veux danser un peu la grande différence
que j'ai fait entre la science
réapproprier d'une part c'est à dire
l'idée que c'est ça vraiment ce que j'ai
essayé d'amener ces cas-là fois on a une
vision dans ce que j'appelle de régime
numérique des savoirs actuellement 2 le
milieu institutionnel et nationale
publique de la recherche se réapproprier
les savoirs par rapport à des abus
d'acteurs privés dans le but d'ouvrir
les savoirs à la société est une autre
vision qui est elle aussi que je partage
plus c'est de dire que les savoirs c'est
pas seulement les académiques des
universitaires qui les détiennent
mais que les savoirs ils sont déjà dans
la société qui circulent déjà dans
l'idée du wiki de cette idée de
valorisation de savoir nécessaire de
remixes des savoirs qui vont qui vont
les qui vont finalement permettre leur
valorisation qui soit plus costaud plus
solide plus divers prix variés et que
ces savoirs il circule déjà dans la
société et qui sont pas seulement
produit par des universitaires et que un
ensemble d'acteurs actuellement variés
produit des savoirs et qui sont
peut-être plus diverses et qu'il s'agit
là non pas d'ouvrir mes deux finalement
de garantir qu'ils continuent à circuler
avec cette idée aussi de été très forts
de l'idéal et de l'imaginaire d'internet
d'une dune société peer-to-peer ses
terres
la terre ou voilà qui utilisent cette
méthode scientifique avec l'idée de de
vérification de méthodes scientifiques
pour valider ces savoirs mais que les
savoirs y circulent déjà et ce qu'il
faut c'est éviter qu'à ce qu'on appelle
dans le vocabulaire des communs des
enclos zur c'est à dire des personnes
des plateformes même aujourd'hui qu'ils
reprennent qui referme si savoir qui les
empêchent de circuler
et là c'est ça qui est super intéressant
parce que on se rapproche beaucoup d'une
métaphore du vivant de cette idée que
d'écosystèmes qu'à un écosystème qui
fonctionne et c'est pour ça dans ma tête
j'ai parlé de la vitalité aussi d'un
système c'est à dire que plus les
savoirs circulent sont interopérables
plus un système tu vois il est vivant et
il va pouvoir fonctionner et c'est un
peu ce renversement de d'état d'esprit
qui est à comprendre entre d'un point de
vue les savoirs voilà c'est une
propriété et il va falloir les partager
et un autre point de vue où les savoirs
ils sont déjà ouverts et ce qu'il faut
c'est garantir leur circulation et
mettre en place des règles des normes
pour pouvoir les garantir dans un
écosystème donné donc voilà ce que j'ai
essayé vraiment de montrer avec beaucoup
plus de descriptions ou dans ma thèse
mais et c'est ça ça a été mon tout mon
travail de comprendre c'est quand tu
passes d'un référentiel à l'autre ta
vision à trans
elle est complètement transformé parce
que les savoirs ils sont déjà ouverts 2
non car l'art 2 mais je me situe pas sur
wikipédia ça s'est vu huawei il ya cette
idée de wikipédia de bas de tous ces
projets de coproduction et ce que je que
j'ai vraiment essayé de montrer c'est on
passe d'une science en société c'est à
dire une science avec l'idée qu'il faut
faire participer toute la société aux
prises de décision donc dans cette idée
de démocratisation des savoirs d'ouvrir
la science parce que tout un chacun on
est dans un incident en une d'un mode de
prise de décision actuellement qui est
beaucoup plus ouverts c'est un réseau
d'acteurs où on n'est plus sous forme de
controverses aussi c'est à dire que tout
le monde doit avoir à fait
c'est au fait si un scientifique pour
pouvoir prendre ses décisions à quelque
chose
donc ça c'est une première vision une
chance en société et moi ce que j'ai
appelé une société en sciences c'est à
dire que la société de plus en plus
quand on est chercheur même quand on est
chercheur dans une entreprise et autres
on va utiliser par exemple quand on fait
des datas science des méthodes
scientifiques pour pouvoir faire sa
science et que aussi des acteurs etc
c'est mon cas c'est à dire que il ya
toute une recherche action une recherche
participative qui se met en place
où il ya des personnes qui sont
peut-être pas dans le milieu
universitaire mais comment doctorat ou
qu'on a un master et qui peuvent
appliquer leurs connaissances dans des
domaines tels que l'écologie telle que
la santé tels que plein de domaines et
que ces savoirs ses compétences elles
sont déjà dans la société et qui feint
il faut les articuler donc c'est
vraiment une vision ainsi et un rapport
de pouvoir ou la légitimité des savoirs
n'est pas seulement dans la sphère
académique et universitaire mais elle
est peut-être dans le domaine et il
s'agit de s'organiser collectivement
pour que la qualité des savoirs qui sont
produits avec tous ses pairs aussi on a
beaucoup beaucoup de
on parle de fake news donc de tous à 2
par rapport à toute cette circulation
d'informations
comment est-ce qu'on garantit aussi
toujours ce questionnement scientifique
cette curiosité
voici tout ce travail de de
scientificité de critères à faire avec
moi un point aussi importante c'est de
montrer qu'on n'a pas seulement la
recherche quantitative positivise basé
sur les emails et data mais il ya
d'autres paradigmes de recherche de
recherche qualitative de recherche qu'on
appelle constructiviste mais aussi de
paradigme de recherche de recherche
actions de science participative qui
sont aussi très intéressant qui ont
peut-être pas les mêmes vocation qu'on a
pas les mêmes critères de scientificité
mais qui font avancer le schmiblick plus
global de compréhension de ce qu'ont
fait de notre société
non plus le côté humanité mais qui est
nécessaire et que tout ne se comprend
pas seulement par des datas et c'est
toute cette diversité qui est pour moi
aussi et là je te parle d'un point de
vue aussi le plus engagé à la fin de ma
thèse mais qui est essentiel à faire
comprendre et comment est-ce qu'on ne
rentrent pas dans un monde qui est
seulement un monde quantitatif
d'évaluation d'évaluation de mesure
n'est qu'à d'autres choses peut-être
plus qualitative à articuler aussi
années qu'il s'agit de penser je veux
revenir aussi sur le capteur à la
séparation entre la collecte de données
l'analyse de données le fait que de plus
en plus tant sur des projets je pense
beaucoup à l'astrophysique quantités
énormes de données qui sont collectés
puis qui sont partagés et puis après
n'importe qui peut traiter ces données
faire sa propre reine et des données je
pense que c'est un des trucs vraiment
récent et qui je voue à son génial et ça
permet vraiment fait déjà chauffé
errances de métiers différents fait
d'aller collecter les données c'est très
difficile de combler le trou en biologie
et traiter les données aussi est
difficile en tant que tel et je trouve
ça intéressant de me séparer ces
disciplines
ouais et par rapport à ça si tu vois ce
qu'on étudie beaucoup aussi en sts c'est
cette idée que on a on a souligné de la
science on est un grand thème la science
le problème c'est que à l'intérieur de
la science les façons de produire la
recherche
on parle de en termes alors à l'argon un
terme qu'on utilise ces communautés
épistémique c'est à dire que chaque
communauté de recherche à des pratiques
différentes
tu parlais de l'astrophysique par
exemple dans le domaine de l'astronomie
ce qui est assez marrant c'est que à
chaque fois qu'on parlait de partage de
données je suis allé dans des
conférences fidjis mais nous ça fait
quand même longtemps qu'on fait ça ça
fait longtemps qu'on a eu le besoin par
exemple en physique en astronomie dans
ces disciplines la d'être déjà dans un
travail mutuelle et collectifs parce
qu'on a besoin de collecter ça coûte
très cher tout ce qu on a besoin de
travailler déjà ils ont mis depuis
longtemps en place des bases de données
pour travailler ensemble ils ont cette
culture du partage parce que c'est
nécessaire pour pouvoir travailler
dessus
mais ce qui est très différent par
exemple
dans deux disciplines alors même si en
biologie on commence à y venir je te
parlais un peu des irm et autres où on
était moins dans cette culture là où
parce que la collecte et elle était
longue ça prenait du temps et peut-être
moins ce besoin de mutualiser en tout
cas il y avait aussi des enjeux de je
garde mes données
parce que il ya aussi toujours que cet
enjeu la de la prend du temps à
collecter
donc je dois garder mes données fermé
pendant un moment
parce que ça prend énormément de temps
de le faire et qu'il ya toute cette
logique compétitive derrière de
publication et ça sert c'est un énorme
qui fait que aussi par rapport à l'idéal
de la science de vouloir tout partager
on est dans des logiques économiques qui
font que des logiques compétitif qui
font qu'on peut pas tout partager et
c'est souvent quelque chose qu'un
presque une attitude schizophrénique
chez les chercheurs entre cette envie de
partager mais cette obligation de de
garder fermée aussi certaines choses
parce que il faut publier avant et
autres et parfois c'est vrai mais
personne et moi c'est aussi quelque
chose qui m'a fait quitter la recherche
entre eux entre cette envie de partager
de sentir qu aussi qu'en termes de
recherche de qualité de pouvoir discuter
partager faire à plusieurs avaient avait
plus d'impact et en termes de qualité de
la recherche et des plus intéressantes
que de devoir garder fermées et c'est
pour ça que dans l'open si ce qui est
intéressant de voir c'est que c'est pas
ouvrir tout à n'importe qui ouvert tous
dès le départ ses pensées l'ouverture à
différents moments à différentes
temporalités pour trouver finalement
quelque chose ou actuellement dans le
système économique de la recherche dans
laquelle on est ne pas se tirer une
balle entre guillemets donc mais voilà
pour te dire aussi que quand on parle de
science tu parles de l'astrophysique
mais il ya des pratiques qui sont qui
sont différentes selon les disciplines
et aux îles qui collectent des données à
plusieurs îles dans ses bases de données
de plus depuis longtemps et sur
l'analyse de données que tu que tu
pointes
il ya beaucoup de changements
actuellement qui se font avec
les mais avec le travail sur des données
de plus en plus massives qui ont amené
bas dans la physique dans l'astronomie
et c'est quelque chose où on travaille
sur des données massives depuis
longtemps mais qui a été une certaine
révolution
par exemple en bio avec la naissance ce
tu vois tout ce qui est bio statistique
qui s'est développée et maintenant
toutes ces approches de data science et
ses approches de data saillantes ce site
il se retrouve maintenant aussi dans les
sciences humaines et sociales et qui
sont des pratiques pour eux c'est pas
dans leur antre limay dans la culture du
partage de travailler en plusieurs
et ça ça crée des reconfigurations
détention que voilà moi j'ai étudié que
j'étudie et qui nécessite aussi de ba de
faire comprendre de donner cette vision
prix global pour que les chercheurs
comprennent qu est ce qui se passe dans
la recherche aujourd'hui pourquoi ça se
transforme et facilité des dialogues qui
qui sont parfois complexes parce que
d'un point de vue à nice de donner enfin
vu qu'on passe dans un monde de l'ordre
de jeux de données notamment de logis où
officie dans plein de domaines jean
avant si on n'avait que cinq données
frappé de données y avait qu'une seule
façon d analyser une certaine manière
alors que maintenant qu'on a des énormes
jeu des données on peut regarder sous
plein d'angles différents
il ya beaucoup plus de valeur à rangs
des jeunes et poutres tuer les données
collectées beaucoup plus réalisable par
différentes personnes
simon baker dans peut-être que ce soit
public
c'est ça et puis aussi questionné parce
que c'est à j'avais vu une présentation
siens intéressante situés sur les dates
assaillent en dessous ça situe c'est à
dire que tu peux être dans des analyses
des normes jeux de données mais pas
forcément à voir le recul d'une
discipline d'un questionnement d'une
méthode scientifique où tu vas faire
juste finalement des computer science
mais pas forcément du et je pense que tu
t'y connais mais quoi mais un jeu de
données selon ce qu'on fait comme un ali
d'où la nécessité de questionner les
analyses qui sont faites on peut faire
sortir un peu tout et n'importe quoi
donc
d'où la nécessité dans les data science
c'est j'avais bien aimé cette idée que
c'est la rencontre entre les computer
science
donc tout ce qui est informatique mais
si les normes bâle fait du monde
numérique dans lequel on compte génère
énormément de données mais aussi les
technologies qui acquit évoluer aussi
les les recherches là dessus qu'ils
évoluent sur les dates assaillantes mais
il la rencontre entre computer science
un champ de un domaine une discipline et
et ses data et c'est ça qui est
intéressant de voir parce que si t'as
pas cet ancrage aussi même puis
interdisciplinaire mais dans un
questionnement scientifique et autres tu
peux faire tout et n'importe quoi donc
c'est aussi important de voilà de
pouvoir finalement dans les analyses à
porter un regard aussi sur d'où viennent
ces analyses comment elles sont faites
qu'est ce qui est fait d'où l'importance
de tout ce qui est traçabilité et
compréhension derrière bas les
algorithmes qui sont mises en place
qu'est ce qui a été fait qu'elle crée tu
mens et ont été faits quel traitement
est en fait sur les données
mais quel traitement aussi ont été faits
sur tout ce qui est une partie hypra
importantes quant à des données
hétérogènes sur le nettoyage des données
la structuration des données tu vas
faire pour les mettre en base de données
qui sont loin d'être anodins et qui font
ce qu'on appelle en sts tout un travail
de d'attaché ping donc de de façonnage
des données et qui n'est pas neutre
parce que selon ta vision tu vas oriente
et à base de nos des tubes à orienter la
lecture que tu vas pouvoir faire des
données d'une certaine façon c'est ce
qu'on a avec constance autour de driss
et de projets des articles qu'on a qu'on
a étudié c'est de montrer aussi que
toute cette mise en vue des données elle
n'est pas neutre selon quel format tu
travailles tu vas avoir pu certaines
choses tu vas faire des liens donc tous
à tous qui et comment tu façonne ces
données là comment tu call une
infrastructure qui utilisent
comment tu vas venir requêté ces données
aussi bas finalement ça nécessite se
questionner ban a tous voila c'est
important les données collectées comme
ça comme une structure complexe et à
chaque fois qu'on le regarde on les
regarde sous un angle plus certaine
manière et du coup on voit sous cet
angle et il ya plein de l'angle sous
lequel on peut le voir voir sous un
angle permet de voir certaines choses et
donc l influence qu on puisse être des
biais possibles en des billets appétit
j'ai donc souhaitant voir un très beau
coup d'interpeller changer notre façon
d'interpréter les données et que c'est
c'est intéressant de le faire face aux
saveurs et questionner sur la
visualisation aussi parce que c'est
quelque chose que sur la mito moi je
suis une grande fan de la méthodologie
moi ce qui me passionne c'est étudié les
étudier j'adore mon maître avec un
chercheur les comprendre ce qui fait et
comment il le fait et donc étudier les
méthodes l'évolution des méthodes et
c'est ce qui me passionne kouassi c'est
un peu une ce qu'on appelle une
anthropologie de laboratoire mais tu
vois si c'est vraiment ça que j'aime
faire pour comprendre parce que c'est
plus c'est plus vaste maintenant c'est
pas seulement aux recherches
on fait ça c'est dans les entreprises
pour l'analyse des toutes nos données et
c'est des enjeux énormes sociétaux et
tout l'enjeu aussi c'est sur les
visualisations par exemple quand
utilisent des outils de cartographie et
autres il ya beaucoup de recherches qui
sont faire tout ce que je dis c'est et
je pourrai partager toute la
bibliographie ça vient d'une d'études en
sciences humaines et sociales surtout
surtout cela sur un fps et autres donc
je m'appuie bien sûr sur une littérature
il est plein de travaux de chercheurs là
dessus donc voilà il ya plein de choses
plein d'articles que je peux partager où
je peux mettre à disposition d'une
bibliographie là dessus donc je suis
loin de c'est pas célia qui parle si je
m'appuie sur toute cette communauté bien
sûr qui travaille là dessus mais voilà
par exemple les visualisations l'outil
là il ya eu un autre chercheur
dans le laboratoire kostek qui a étudié
un logiciel qui s'appelle g fit donc je
sais pas si tu connais c'est pour faire
de la cartographie qui voilà tous les
seuls qu'on utilise qu'est ce qu'on va
faire qu'est ce qu'on va mettre en avant
et qui après oriente puisque en date
assaillantes sonné beaucoup sur des
itérations tu vas visualiser quelque
chose qui va t'amener à retravailler des
données et autres donc et tout ça bah il
atteint 2 micros processus cognitif
aussi qu'ils sont chers et qu'il s'agit
de de questionner ou en tout cas de de
rendre compte je pense que c'est en
effet il ya plein de pièges potentiels
est bon en ce moment on peut ça c'est un
petit peu je pense qu'on prépare à deux
cuisses des statistiques en ce moment il
ya makan abstrait statistiques et les
statistiques une revue de statistiques
qui a publié en mars dernier ses 54
articles sur les problèmes aujourd'hui
en statistiques et tous les défauts des
statistiques écrits sont utilisés
aujourd'hui est tel qu'on les enseignes
aujourd'hui et il ya énormément de
problèmes et il ya une pleine crise et
les gens à ses devoirs quand est-ce
qu'on peut mieux faire de l'analyse de
données est un des trucs qui ressort
notamment ses failles plusieurs quelques
trucs qui ressortent c'est intéressant
mais un des trucs qui ressort c'est
vraiment l'importance de l'expertisé de
et du contexte dans l'alizé donné que je
suis pas juste de regarder les données
tel quel il faut les prendre dans le
contexte les métadonnées sont
importantes
comment elles ont été collectées est ce
qui est des biais de sélection genre de
choses et puis les expertises
est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on sait déjà
quoi est-ce que ça peut aider à mieux
comprendre les données les interpeller
mais tu voi écrites entre guillemets
c'est crise là elles sont le sillon
d'une et si ça qui est important je
pense à faire à comprendre et ça c'est
quelque chose depuis longtemps que pas
kim qui me tient à coeur
déjà que je travaillais sur plus le côté
communication scientifique avec
mousesports qu'on avait publié un
article sur tu sais le boson de higgs
voilà où on s'était dit que c'était 99
9% de chances ce qu'on trouve le boson
de higgs
mais si tu veux c'est là c'est une
grande problématique et je pense qu'on y
vient c'est que faire comprendre que la
science est mouvant et que une chance
vivante
c'est une recherche qui se remet en
cause ou bien sûr qu'il ya déjà des
crises à un moment mais c'est normal
c'est à dire que une théorie c voilà
c'est fait pour c'est un modèle à un
moment pour aider à penser mais ça mais
ça ne reste qu'un modèle sinon ça se
transforme en un dogme et et c'est dur
parce que ça nécessite de se remettre en
cause plus tous les enjeux financiers et
économiques qui sont qui sont derrière
finalement et même pour un un chercheur
si tu veux de caen il a une théorie
autres de parfois c'est toute sa vie et
de remettre en cause quand il ya une
théorie qui est remis en cause
c'est aussi des certitudes qui
s'évanouissent et c'est pas simple en
tant que c'est pour ça que pour moi
c'est très important de toujours aussi
tu fais entre guillemets les chercheurs
c'est passionnant d esprit c des
personnes avec des émotions avec qui vit
dans un certain contexte qui fait qu'ils
vont réagir d'une certaine façon de 6
pouces et pas comme jeudi par par des
logiques aussi compétitive très forte
face à un manque de moyens si surtout en
france donc c'est ça aussi à prendre en
considération et que c'est normal qu'ils
aient des et tant mieux qu'ils aient des
remises en cause et que ça permet et
c'est intéressant aussi au plus grand
public de dire que c'est pas c'est pas
la fin de leurs intrigues mais c'est pas
la fin de la science est telle qu'elle
se fait en part par par petits
changements par roque questionnement par
le fait aussi que nos propres savoirs et
nos propres technologies transforment
notre société transporte notre monde qui
va faire que ça va changer aussi plus
anciens du men mais notre société et
donc il ya toujours ces boucles entre un
monde il n'est pas figé aussi et que
c'est émouvant
et voilà qu'il faut qu'il faut être
serein entre quand il ya des crises tant
mieux c'est ça permet de remettre un peu
un peu de mouvements de temps que tout
ça et de sueur questionner et je pense
que c'est ça qui est super actuellement
avec si toutes ces approches moi que je
questionne beaucoup autour c'est un
sujet de recherche en tantale d'une
machine learning dubai et dynamisme de
tous à 2 voilà quelle est la façon aussi
dont on conçoit la science dont on
conçoit le cerveau humain aussi
et comment ces influences aussi la façon
dont va faire de la recherche et donc
voilà c'est sur place et la science dans
à la fois dans une société dans un
contexte mais aussi dans un corps et
dans une des fonctions cognitives
données qui font qu'on est dans des
techniques qui font qu'on va devoir
analyser et bien avancé je pense de
faire les sciences bouge énormément
autrement de plein d'aspects blessés ont
dû aussi aux technologies et enfin qu'on
parlait des éditeurs par exemple
aujourd'hui les éditeurs ils font pas le
même métier qu'avant parce que
maintenant il ya internet et hier je
sais pas comment ça se passerait à
l'époque pour faire des terreaux du
temps c'était beaucoup plus compliqué
que aujourd'hui filet sur internet on
peut dire le truc télécharger écrire
l'art dû renvoyer sa cinquième rang des
choses ça change aussi amazon et pour
partager des bases de données
à l'époque c'était plus compliqué ça
change les façons de concessions
sociales
c'est ça si tu veux et c'est ça tu
l'avais bien dit ça change les manières
dont on raisonne c'est à dire que c'est
vraiment ça qui est important de
comprendre comment le numérique comment
cette technologie de la façonnent nos
modes de pensée nos modes d'action aussi
et finalement à l'e-book que j'ai fait
c'est de dire que finalement c'était que
linger internet et autres ça vient ainsi
de propre des idéaux de certains
chercheurs à une époque beaucoup dans
une façon de penser aussi la société
autour de la cybernétique et autres qui
ont influencé la production de ces de
ces technologies qui font que finalement
ces imaginaires aussi de
de cybernétique de peer-to-peer d'auto
organisation ont été possibles ont été
rendue possible avec internet
puis le web et qui finalement face à nos
nous façon d'être et d'agir de façon
plus collaborative et comme tu le dit
très bien je tente c'est un point
important à souligner c'est à dire que
nos des usages qu'on fait des
technologies de musique qui nous
paraissent entre guillemets naturel est
inné il faut jamais oublier que notre
façon de d'utiliser la technologie et
notre conception des mets du numérique
est différente d'autres personnes qui
ont peu qu'on peut être pas eu les mêmes
usages et et qu'il faut toujours se
mettre aussi à la place des autres
ou peut-être tu vois faire c est pour ça
que j'aime ces immersions en signe on
fait avec driss des immersions
pratiquants formation de l'est de mettre
des personnes qu'on pas l'habitude du
code de la programmation dans un univers
un peu de programmation pour vraiment
comprendre finalement mettra dans la
peau d'un programmeur et comprendre que
ça fonctionne de façon plus
collaborative et autres et c'est par ces
immersions con qu'on dépasse aussi des
peurs parce que bah c'est pas simple
d'utiliser moi je vois bien certaines
personnes bah peur de casser la machine
in peur de faire une erreur
donc faut pour être aussi entre
guillemets toujours avoir cette prise de
recul de on a différents usages
différents points de vue et qui avait
peur aussi parfois et voilà qu'il faut
respecter ça aussi et c'est important
aussi dans la formation
je pense le savez ça fait pas ça
je prends l'exemple de snapshot j'ai
essayé d'utiliser une fois slap shot et
je suis sentie tellement vieux je peux
arriver à rien faire je crois que j'ai
eu la même là même où tu vois des trucs
c'est bête mais hier on utilise riot qui
est comme un stade où discorde
tu vois pour partager en un canal et moi
j'ai l'habitude j'aime bien les mecs
parce que voilà c'est un truc et la
salle et dans tous les sens vous pouvez
jamais forés dans l'historique et je me
dis voilà bon et c'est toujours bien de
se dire voilà je crois que tu découvres
un nouvel outil où tu vas c'était tout
bêtement pour te dire j'étais débile
devant une télé et il fallait branché
j'avais tout branché j'avais touché au
bouton milian un bouton derrière pour
allumer la télé et je ne l'avais pas vue
et donc tu vois un truc où j'ai plus
l'habitude non voilà c'est faux petit
comprendre que les usages une question
d'habitude et la confiance que tu
entends quelque chose c'est parce que
voilà un moment et et qu' on est tous un
peu stupide
à un moment donné sur des choses dont tu
as mal n'a pas l'habitude et c'est
travailler sur ce manque de confiance et
se bat c'est toujours cette curiosité de
dire bah voila j arrive peut-être pas
mais je vais essayer et qui est
important c'est l'inversé une vidéo sur
qui est passé sur twitter où des jeunes
d'aujourd'hui s'ils utilisaient un
téléphone des années 90 voire 120 mètres
devant un minitel quoi ou à qui voient
des choses je sais pas où ça tu as déjà
fait le coup tu étais sur ta tablette et
après tu utilises ton ordinateur et
essaye de scrollé ton écran tu vois où
est donc on est là sa montre et c'est ça
qui est marrant ça montre comment va ton
cerveau il s'habitue très vite à
certaines chaînes ils perdent l'habitude
et et c'est toujours en rire en rire
mais c'est ces petits moments qui te
font prendre conscience que tu es
souvent dans des habitués aussi à un
certain design quelque chose et et c'est
bien ainsi parfois et c'est ce qu'on
fait beaucoup avec driss d'ouvrir le
capot c'est à dire que c'est bien aussi
d'être fasse de nouveau à une difficulté
une complexité
parce que
et c'est un grand un c'est un enjeu
énorme c'est à dire on fait tout avec
tout ce qui est unique ce design du sel
design aux utilisateurs pour un facile
et intuitif
le fonctionnement est plus avancée mais
mais c'est important de voir et c'est la
même chose autour des recommandations et
autres et moi c'est grand sujet qui me
passionne et qui sont qui sont très
politiques qui sont ceux de voilà
qu'elles sont tous les qui sont moi que
je mets les travaux de monaco directeur
de thèse était sur la notion de
capitalisme cognitif qui sont liés a
finalement un capitalisme basé sur les
forces de travail les forces cognitives
mais de plus en plus moi et c'est la fin
de ma thèse là dessus de dire qu'on est
plus seulement sur un management par
projet on est sur un management
cognitifs c'est à dire que tueur du
design une économie de l'attention du
design ça va être vraiment les
plateformes en tant que tel avec toutes
les suggestions toutes les
recommandations qui font que c'est
facile et c'est intuitif plus des
processus qu'il s'agit vraiment de
questionner qui est celle de qui sont
beaucoup plus émotionnel on marche sur
le clic onze matches sur l'émotion et
c'est dur de résister à ce que ces
marchés sur des notifications sur
l'émotion le lien et d'où un autre sujet
qui me passionne et que que je creuse là
autour d'une association qui est aussi
en train de créer sur sa peine l'encré
des savoirs s'est questionné aussi tout
ce que ses besoins actuellement de
prendre du cal de prendre du recul avec
la mutation moi je suis lâche prof de
yoga mais c'est finalement recréer un
espace cognis yves où on sent qu
actuellement et c'est de plus en plus
fort tu as déjà sur la pub y avait
énormément de chose de fermé où on sent
qu'on nie que ces bulles la de capacité
de penser par soi-même et d'une
réflexion critique sont de plus en plus
limité de park on va soit renforcée par
des informations qui rentre dans ta
bulle et qui vont pas terminé à penser
d'autres choses tu restes dans ta
microbulles ce pas aussi finalement oui
jouer sur sur plein de choses qui font
que ça va aller dans son sens et dans le
sens si cognitivement de assez bien je
me sens bien tu vois donc c'est aussi
toutes ces technologies qui agissent
vraiment sûr sur des systèmes
d'addiction au final de récompenses et
que et qui rejoignent toutes les
problématiques de sciences cognitives
donc moi je boucle avec mes patients sur
les sciences cognitives et comme je le
dis je suis pas du tout la seule et là
dessus c'est ça qui est passionnant
c'est que j'ai quinze mille choses à
apprendre
c'est comme un énorme champ de recherche
qui s'ouvraient à moi et que j'espère
faire comme je je pense pas faire de
l'académique jeu j'espère pouvoir
continuer à creuser avec des chercheurs
douce est aussi quelque chose qui me
tient à coeur de cette société en
sciences c'est à dire que peut-être que
je serai pas dans la recherche mais j'ai
envie de continuer à être en dialogue
avec les chercheurs d'où cette nécessité
d' open sayans de science ouverte à ce
sujet il ya un peu de casse s'appelle
dior une divided tention 104 qui vient
d'être lancé les pros cat épisode c'est
300 et s'est fait à un des co créateur
c'est tristan harrison ancien employé de
google qui travaille beaucoup sur des
sur les mécanismes d'addiction pour
google que par des produits google est
vraiment le thème de son truc qui met un
super toc ou dont ils pas loin de ses
six industries à maximiser la tension
que facebook google/youtube twitterer
tout ça et il parle beaucoup des
conséquences sur ce que j'appelle moi
des effets secondaires sévères que ce
soit on sait c'est pas toi mon objectif
c'est jusqu'où les gens restent sur ces
plateformes
mais pour atteindre ses objectifs
saisie avant conversion comprendre
certaines à certaines stratégies et
uniquement ça va être des addictions et
sa ses rangs des effets secondaires de
l'objectif de ces décisions mais ces
effets secondaires sont très
préoccupants en termes d'information a
parlé mais aussi je pense vraiment la
capacité d'attention entre ses rangs un
sujet montrer son respect beaucoup on
est tellement habitué à voir des
informations brèves choquant et puis on
la lui on passe à autre chose que la
capacité d'attention de près ouais est
très réduite et il ya beaucoup d'études
là dessus et je te dis mince et des
sujets qui n'ont que je bats j'aimerais
ouvre je relis des choses dessus après
le seul souci c'est avoir le temps pour
c'est le problème quand tu fais de la
recherche plus d'un que tu en fais pas
ton métier mais d'un autre côté quand tu
es chercheurs professionnels tu en a
beaucoup qui qui passent leur temps à
rechercher des financements et qui
peuvent pas forcément qui passent
beaucoup de temps plus tu montes en
recherche si plus tu te retrouves
piaillent donc à devoir gérer une équipe
donc tu fais plus vraiment de tu as
moins de temps ci pour ta recherche donc
je me dis bon
quelle est la meilleure solution quel
est le mode le meilleur modèle pour se
questionner sur les savoirs et faire
avancer
donc je pense que chacun doit trouver
son équilibre moi je n'ai pas encore
trouvé mais en tout cas voilà beaucoup
de travaux un psycho logis et autres sur
y avait aussi un livre qui était sorti
je sais plus d'une une américaine sur
cette idée de en ce sens seul en étant
connecté je sais plus le nom je pourrais
être le retrouver je crois qu'elle était
à microsoft loi facebook où elle c'était
une chercheuse
je sais plus sont ensuite je te
retrouverai mais voilà sur cette idée
que j'ai lu la en ligne j'avais fait un
stage à lucia cette façon francisco avec
un chercheur qui s'appelle ghazaleh
l'âme cazalet dans son labo en master et
qui vient de publier un bouquin qui
s'appelle est bien certain temps ce de
distracted mind et voilà de d'apporter
c'est toujours on revient sur un modèle
théorique qu'il s'agit de questionner
mais qui peut aider à penser à un moment
donné sur l'idée que oui on
on a on a une prise de recul tout ce
qu'on appelle métacognition qui était
assez bas et de l'autre côté tout ce qui
est anxieux t et ennuis vont faire qu'on
va être à la recherche d'une nouveauté à
la recherche de notification et que tout
travail de fond est dur tu vois c'est
compliqué et que finalement ces
technologies et joue là dessus elle joue
sur c'est à besoin d'être connecté parce
que aussi c'est fois c'est flippant
d'être on a plus ça s'apprend tu vois
d'être d'être seul avec soi-même ne rien
faire et delta du stress eh ben c'est
plus simple d'avoir 7
c'est ce retour de rester dans ce flot
là que de poser et de prendre du temps
et d'observer parce que ben il ya des
choses qui peuvent émerger aussi qu'ils
sont qui sont pas simples à gérer
et donc c'est un vrai apprentissage est
vraiment ce lien entre comment est ce
que dans comment se réapproprie sa
aujourd'hui comment se réapproprie c'est
comme ça qu'on va tous que métacognition
m'intéresse beaucoup
c'est à dire à cette prise de recul sur
c'est ce que j'ai fait aussi dans ma
tâche de finale c'était aussi une méta
t'es une méta recherche sur quels sont
les façons de penser la recherche
aujourd'hui la science est donc 2 voilà
sept métacognition deux à la fois
individuellement mais collectivement de
dire où on est qu'est-ce qu'on fait ou
on va est important et oui ici c'est
pour ça qu'il ya beaucoup actuellement
un engouement par exemple de programme
des méditations de différentes méthodes
et avec aussi une critique qu'on peut
faire et là vraiment dans l'association
est en train de construire l'encré des
savoirs c'est aussi pourquoi dans notre
société aujourd'hui on a besoin de ça et
qu elles sont aussi parce qu'il ya
toujours des reprises quels sont les
reprises aussi de toutes ces méthodes là
pour dans une dynamique d'efficacité de
performance c'est à dire qu'on est dans
un monde ultra stressée qui va très très
vite
c'est de dire bon bah il faut savoir
gérer pour rester dans ce dans cet état
tu vois de toujours de performance et
d'efficacité
meetic est ce qu'un aussi à ce que est
ce qu'on a besoin d'être aussi efficace
aujourd'hui pourquoi gens pour qu elle
pour quelle raison quoi donc voilà c'est
tout ça que j'aimerais des sujets qui me
passionne et je suis pas la seule à les
traiter mais j'adorerais tu vois
commencer des discussions plus
collective là dessus avec cet axe à la
fois sciences cognitives mais à la fois
plus sciences sociales 100 lumens et un
travail collectif de réflexion quoi donc
je pense que c'est très important
prendre davantage du recul sur ce qu'on
fait aux tirs pour revenir un peu à
l'eau pétillante
est ce que dans ces discussions à ce que
tu as fait son tour de du rôle de la
vulgarisation alors dans ma dans le
terrain d'étude comme je te disais de la
consultation république numérique
il ya eu peu de personnes qui se sont
exprimées à part des personnes qui
travaillent dans des associations ou
autres qui disent ah bah non on a besoin
d'accéder à ses choix tout ce qui est
journalisme et autres d'accéder à ces
publications scientifiques ça par
exemple on avait fait avec un cure pied
jeudi à des fliers sur l'open sciences
et en ayant des petits bonhommes donc le
citoyen le journaliste le hacker le
chercheur le bibliothécaire pour faire
comprendre pourquoi est ce que l'open
saillantes s'était pas seulement pour
les universitaires mais ses hôtes et
aussi pour pour 2 personnes sachant que
les journalistes il a besoin d'accéder à
tout ça donc ça il ya eu voilà au tour
de l'open sérieuses ou de l'open access
6 1
un discours qu'on entend ce qui ce qui a
moins été si tu veux sur la plateforme
sur la consultation des publics
numériques il ya eu au moins le côté
dans science ouverte sur le côté science
citoyenne une science participative et
de vulgarisation aussi un peu moins mais
qui est pour moi alors plus peut-être
sur l'idée et qui rejoint cette idée de
société en sciences c'est à dire de pas
seulement de vulgarisation mais de de
médiation c'est à dire que on donne les
moyens à tout un chacun de comprendre ce
que c'est qu'une méthode scientifique un
processus de recherche pour pouvoir les
inclure dans des projets pas seulement
comme
comme dans des jeux foldit ou autres où
ils sont juste une puissance de calcul
parce qu'on n'a pas encore les capacités
avec les techniques les méthodes
numériques pour pouvoir et l'humain tu
vois la puissance humaine est encore
plus et plus efficace je passe tu
connais fold it pour le tu peux
expliquer alors faillite c'est un jeu
alors je c'était pour le repliement des
protéines
donc si tu veux tu t'amuses sur le jeu à
voir le repliement des protéines
possible et si tu veux c'est un truc en
termes de puissance de calcul numérique
qui est complexe et là le fait que des
intrigues mais d intelligence humaine le
fasse ça permet de faire avancer le
schmilblick très vite mais là c'est
finalement on a une vision des sciences
citoyennes de dire que c'est une
puissance de calcul où on se sert de
l'intelligence humaine pour pouvoir
aller plus vite dans des choses en
termes de puissance de calcul on est
encore limitée et c'est très différent
d'une approche de sciences inclusive ou
de recherche action inclusive où on dit
que en termes d idées qui vont émerger
des projets de recherche par exemple en
santé autres on inclut aussi des savoirs
les visions par exemple des patients qui
connaissent plein de choses sur la
maladie et qui repose encore tu vois
cette question souvent de le docteur qui
connaît ou le chercheur qui connaît et
les patients comme pas de ça ces combats
de savoir donc tu vois tu les questions
de légitimité des savoirs et mais ça ça
peut été abordé dans la consultation
république numérique comme et moi c'est
quelque chose et c'est quelque chose
avec un cure pieds 10 et d'autres
acteurs voilà ces deux pour une chance
pleinement ouverte
c'est aussi casser un peu ces rapports
d'autorité entre les chercheurs d'un
côté et il est d'autres personnes et de
comment est-ce qu'on alors pas dire que
tout le monde des chercheurs mais de
dire qu'on peut former les personnes à
développer aussi un esprit scientifique
longtemps en ayant ainsi une critique
sur qu'est ce que c'est qu'un esprit
scientifique mais voilà ça sert
je sais pas si ça répond à ta question
peut-être que c'est à orienter un peu
différemment
ouais parce que l'observation faire
c'est que en des domaines comme les
mathématiques l'informatique allée des
articles sont déjà souvent sur arxiv
accessible facilement contre le problème
c'est plus que article est écrit pour
des professionnels et même parfois avant
je vois que je reste moi je pensais
beaucoup de chercheurs faire exprès
d'écrire des articles en maths plus
compliqués qu'ils en ont l'air pour se
donner ce plus facile de publier après
du coup il ya un défi passé ccc open au
sens oui c'est un accessible mais c'est
pas accessible au sens facile d'accès à
l'essence collectif on va dire du coup
il ya vraiment un enjeu de explications
et je parle de vulgarisation paraît trop
grand s'impliquer le rythme est passée
juste expliqué le truc
un autre chercheur en mathématiques
classe écrit pense qu'il n'y a pas assez
d'efforts dans cette direction et c'est
pire que ça c'est que c'est souvent
c'est pas si bien vu ces chercheurs
faire ce genre de travail donc pas donc
il ya le site de shon carroll qui a un
excellent vulgarisateur en physique qui
a écrit plusieurs bouquins avec tout ça
et décrivait s'il a écrit sur son blog
qui déconseillait décrire débutant alors
faire la vulgarisation d'une façon
générale même d'écrire des bouquins même
des ebooks heures de cours lorsqu on m
appelle tenir travail avant d'être enfin
titulaire universités américaines et du
coup la vulgarisation est vraiment pas
encourager je pense que ça change un
petit peu mais bas par rapport à ça je
vais plus alors moi - ce que parce que
comme je t'ai dit ya tout le travail de
tests que j'ai pu faire mais qui a qui
naît de questionnements collectif pas
qu'on a commencé maintenant il ya six
ans avec à curepipe vie on est peut-être
en train de transformer la pour inclure
pas seulement des docteurs
il ya plus y'a pas seulement des
doctorants dans l'association mais
peut-être par les deux actrices search
ou ailleurs on va voir le nom qu'on va
donner mais sur cette idée de nous qui
nous a tous par exemple le président de
l'association c'est ma culotte un jour
qu'elle lui qui fait de la médiation
scientifique depuis longtemps il l'a
fait partie d'associations terme
d'astronomie et on travaille vraiment
sur cette idée sur cette différence si
tu veux entre accès et accessibilité
ce qui est important à comprendre c'est
que oui ton contenu il peut être on peut
y accéder mais que toute la contractent
la compréhension de l'accessibilité
c'est à dire rendre accessible à la fois
cognitivement un contenu que tu puisse
vraiment l'intégrer et quelque chose de
complexe où pareille ça peut être mise
en ligne
mais on en parlait des usages tout à
l'heure si c'est quelque chose qui est
compliqué tu vois et bah il ya aussi des
barrières de maîtrise d'un outil de
techniques qui sont pas donné à tout le
monde et qui ça nécessite pas aussi de
là un apprentissage et une éducation et
nous par rapport à ça dans le cube piège
dit c'est vrai que depuis le début on a
voulu réfléchir a déjà ses cours à
l'open ça lance donc avant que ce soit à
la entre guillemets à la mode
on en parle beaucoup et il y en avait
d'autres 1 qui abordait on a finalement
ici est de s'insérer dans un réseau
comprendre le réseau qui est qui qui
participait c'est pour ça que moi par
exemple on à faire une campagne de
financement participatif pour faire un
voyage aux etats-unis qui a permis de
rencontrer des personnes engagées dans
l'open saillantes
donc ça c'était il ya six ans et si
chouette avec tous les lieux aussi
alternative des meilleurs space d'un
hacker space toi c'était aussi en
ébullition à cette époque là et là
dessus on a aussi toujours eu à coeur de
travailler sur les formats sur les
formats qui permettent de faire
comprendre un public plus large
certaines choses et c'est pour ça je te
parlais des flyers donc on est beaucoup
aussi bas sur l'idée d'un guide ulysse
trélat science ouverte donc très
importante aussi des des images des
formats de la bdm aussi tu vois
bd un peu humoristique qui permettent de
prendre du recul qui permettent il ya
plein de choses qui sont faites en
sciences là dessus c'est super ce qui
est fait aujourd'hui ses efforts de de
se mettre à la place deux pour expliquer
des choses et ça je pense que toi tu vas
voilà tu es au coeur de tout ça dans ses
questionnements d'enter dans l'est aussi
dans les toutes les vidéos que tu fais
et c'est chouette de voir tout ça aussi
c'était bliss yankee qui appuient se
mettre en place aussi sûr sur youtube
sur d'autres plateformes départ avec les
podcasts pour faire faire comprendre ses
enjeux d'accessibilité et qui sont des
enjeux comme tu le disais très bien de
ce qu'on appelle en sciences sociales de
savoir pouvoir c'est à dire que ceux qui
détiennent le savoir ce qu'on le pouvoir
aussi donc
donc c'est des choses là c'est des
notions de savoir pouvoir autour de
foucauld qui a beaucoup travaillé là
dessus sur les épices demeo et qui sont
passionnantes et de comprendre que oui
détenir un savoir c'est aussi avoir un
certain pouvoir et que et que finalement
l'ouvrir à d'autres personnes c'est
prendre des risques tout comme faire
développer un esprit critique à
certaines personnes c'est accepter que
ils remettent en cause certaines choses
et que et que si tout l'apprentissage de
tu parlais du jargon c'est à dire
d'utiliser un jargon il faut pas oublier
que oui c'est à dire que les articles 6
et des espaces de l'argumentation de
discussions débats etc c'est aussi où on
peut utiliser certains mécanismes de
rhétorique pour pouvoir faire valoir si
son point de vue est que quand on écrit
voilà il ya aussi tous acquis qui peut
qui peut rentrer en compte et tout ce
qui est les arguments d'autorité aussi
c'est à dire que se servir de sa figure
de chercheurs pour légitimer sa position
donc ça c'est des choses qui peuvent
être utilisés donc on est dans ces
conflits et danser dans un monde qui est
jean discuté hier avec on a fait un
petit apéro open science à strasbourg et
à paris avec à curepipe dit et j'en
discutais avec va un des membres de
l'association allaient qui en qui est en
en sciences humaines et sociales qui
disait qu'au final tout ce domaine de la
rhétorique de l'éloquence de toute cette
culture aussi d humanité tu vois elle
est l et délégitimé dans les domaines
scientifique et ce qui fait ce qu'ils
nous disaient ce qui fait qu'on laisse
ces pouvoirs là et ces méthodes là aux
politiciens qui savent aussi utiliser ça
et que c'est des armes de persuasion
anciennes armes
donc on a à la fois des armes de
persuasion qui sont liées au fait
j'amène ça je suis scientifique et qui
fait que l'effet que si on les
questionne pas et si on n'a pas une
transparence non voilà de dire mais où
il vient de ces faits c'est pas
suffisant de dire ah bah tiens tu sais
tu as le fréquence a été
scientifiquement prouvé ok si tu
questionne pas ça veut dire quoi le
scientifiquement prouvé moi je le voyais
beaucoup dans les milieux du yoga et 6 à
auxi que j'essaye de créer des dialogues
beaucoup de personnes dans le yoga qui
disent les scientifiques ont montré que
8 à des choses derrière tu sens que si
c'est pas du tout scientifique et est
donc tutu à ces arguments aussi
d'autorité et il ya des recherches
sérieuses qui sont faits sur la
méditation et autres et tu vois c'est
des choses à faire comprendre et d'un
autre côté il faut faire comprendre
aussi que en tant que chercheur à des
moments pas ce contrôle dans ce jeu de
l'argumentation de la persuasion
quand on est jeune chercheur aussi tu
vois à utiliser un certain jargon ça met
de la distance
donc ça à soi aussi et que consciemment
ou inconsciemment dans certaines
situations on utilise cette rhétorique
tous ces jeux et qu'il est important je
pense d'eux
pas toujours d'en avoir conscience et
que ces présents c'est à dire que dans
la science est liée aussi à tout et
encore une fois on sait pas seulement
moi c'est tous des domaines en sciences
humaines en sciences de l'information de
la communication qui étudie ça c'est les
articles qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce
que ça représente c'est aussi un endroit
de rétro ricou il ya aussi un ordre
moi j'ai des amis qui sont créés tu mens
automatique des langues qui voit aussi
comment un article est structuré voilà
il ya il ya toute une procédure conduit
il ya des traditions il ya des pratiques
et qu'il soit aussi une certaine
légitime comme tu dis dans certains dans
certains domaines et qui a été critiquée
si tu regardes un peu sur la critique du
postmodernisme avec la sphère sokal
keane affaire où on voit là il ya une
critique autour des des sciences la
recherche plus qualitative des poissons
moderne de dire que c'était que que dès
que du langage et que un article écrit
avec un jargon pas possible finalement
passé dans une revue donc c'est aussi
toute ces c'est encore une fois il y en
a encore récemment tu peux regarder le
carnet qui s'appelle dilsen t-il seul je
sais pas mais qui voit là où on a
toujours ses canulars qui ressorte et
qui montre que voilà la science avec
fait par des chercheurs avec des enjeux
des luttes des produits différents etc
c'est compliqué oui c'est complexe
du coup peut-être commencer le nom de
hacker pêche des meilleures choses que
tu peux brancher un peu ce que c'est bah
voilà à curepipe qui a comme je disais
si on s'est structuré en association
mais au départ on était un collectif je
suis loin d'être des deux salles d'avoir
fondé ça donc on était bas sur ce
questionnement de de se dire mince on
parle beaucoup des open access mais il
ya peut-être d'autres choses aussi à
ouvrir
termes de science d'autres choses nous
ont été très proches des logiciels
libres open source et donc on a on a
créé cette association pour questionner
les pratiques de la recherche et de la
place aussi quand tu es jeune chercheur
quand les doctorants ou jeunes
chercheurs voilà comment est ce que tu
pratiques la recherche aujourd'hui et
comment tu l'ombre aussi à d'autres
personnes et que c'est pas seulement les
chercheurs plafond donc on a commencé ça
a pris parce qu'on s'est rendu compte
que ce qu'on disait sur la recherche
aussi sur tous les enjeux de deux pas de
compétition de ce qu'on appelle publish
or perish de pression s'il était était
présent le milieu le moment le bas thèse
qui est un moment très difficile et que
beaucoup de personnes pensaient ça et on
souffrait mais d'exprimer pas forcément
donc on sait on s'est regroupé comme ça
donc avec comme suit 10 1 un autre
chercheur qui s'appelle guillaume dumas
qui est chercheur en neurosciences
l'institut pasteur maintenant le si
mathieu le champ jour qui était plus en
médiation plus d'acteurs pour d'autres
d'autres toute association ou d'autres
lieux par exemple la paillasse qui était
un hacker space un lieu à l'aube
oratoire ouvert donc c'est finalement
une un moment qu'ils étaient très forts
d'ébullition ou plainte collective plein
d'initiatives c'était le moment où on
parlait beaucoup d'économies
collaborative on dit mais cette capacité
par les blogs par les articles de
pouvoir par twitter aussi de pouvoir
s'exprimer et de créer quelque chose à
plusieurs donc nous voilà on a créé a
cure pays dit là dessus aussi structuré
en association dans l'idée à la fois de
faire une veille sur les sujets de
l'open sky lance donc sur facebook sur
twitter à la fois comprendre quel était
le réseau d'acteurs qui participé à tout
ça
donc en france et à l'international et
comme je disais quelque chose
d'important de travailler sur les
formats pour pouvoir faire comprendre ce
que c'est que la science la recherche
aujourd'hui et l'open sky ans donc voilà
comment on s'y structuré et comment
fonctionne bah on est un petit
des bénévoles qui nous regroupons avec
différents projets qui se mettent en
place la par exemple fourni sur un
projet va surtout à deux autres deux
autres membres
un membre jean baptiste qui a strasbourg
maintenant et il ya gat qui nous a
rejoints sur un projet de traduction
collaborative un d'un livre qui a été
fait en anglais sur l'open saillantes
c'est donc voilà on a commencé cette
traduction là mais avec toujours ce côté
de l'inclure différentes personnes vers
et en annonçant en ligne n'a ce projet
de l'ide illustrée aussi sur la
travailler sur les formats donc voilà on
est sûr surtout ça sachant qu'on en a un
peu de temps et c'est surtout cette idée
d'avoir dû du plaisir à à se rencontrer
à mettre en contact des personnes tu
vois autour d'un verre hier de crédit
dialogue bain et crée aussi je pense à
un écosystème en tout cas une espace
bienveillant pour pouvoir partager ses
idées rencontre et peut être d'autres
personnes dont crée du lien
donc si je pense que c'est quelque chose
et mon avis dire que voilà moi je parle
en tant que tu puis eddy avec mon propre
point de vue mais si tu parles à aller
donc donc je te parlais aller pour
alexandra c'est un brésilien ado sera
différent il te portera peut-être
d'autres éléments mathieu aussi jean
baptiste si guillaume aussi et c'est
l'idée de rester quelque chose ceci de
vivant et là une problématique on se
pose beaucoup on n'est pas du tout les
seuls à se poser c'est quel modèle
économique actuellement pour pour toutes
ces communautés aussi tu vois de
bénévoles qui font des choses pour cal
rétribution pour les communautés et ça
c'est un sujet énorme de modèle
économique avec l'apparition de
coopérative de chercheurs indépendants
de comment est-ce qu'on s'organise
comment est ce qu'on fait du travail
comment gagne comment est-ce qu'on
finance des projets de recherche parce
qu'il ya que le modèle de recherche
académique universitaire à ce qu'il ya
d'autres choses à créer donc ça c'est
c'est des questionnements actuels qui
sont
qui sont présents sur les structures
juridiques économiques à mettre en place
et on est dedans si et on le questionne
aussi donc il y en a plein qui travaille
là dessus et non un peu on a envie de
comprendre voilà c'est toujours cette
idée aussi qui est très présent pourquoi
le terme
ac c'est le terme derrière si tu as un
article de richard stallman qui l'est le
créateur qu'un retrait très fort et
charismatique dans les logiciels libres
dans la free software foundation
derrière le terme hacking c'est aussi
l'idée de l'amusement de joie de
créativité de prendre un prendre un
objet et lui trouver une autre une autre
fonctionnalité donc toujours du jeu
aussi et qui est très important et dans
l'invité du hac c'est l'idée de parfois
ya des blocages et au lieu de perdre de
l'énergie d'aller droit dedans
comment est ce qu'on peut trouver des
alternatives des façons de contourner
pour faire quelque chose qui est censée
la religion donc c'est un peu ce qu'on a
derrière un peu les délits de nature
pillent ding peut-être actu ricerche et
il ya aussi ce côté de pas de
questionner à l'aller les pratiques de
recherche des dossiers un peu technique
parce qu'on a fait beaucoup d'ateliers
par exemple des ateliers qui s'appelait
open bic pour le dire qu'être geek c'est
pas donné à tout le monde entre
guillemets de comprendre aussi tu vois
derrière son ordinateur du codé de
programmer et ça nécessite un
apprentissage aussi la programmation
donc on avait fait des sessions
d'apprentissage de la programmation api
ton qu'on a repris après grâce à
constance que l'on a fait avec avec
driss voilà mes deux d'initiation à la
produit la programmation qui va de
beaucoup dans ton sens de voila
j'aimerais le terme de vulgarisation
mais plus de termes de médiation
d'introduction dans un dans des
écosystèmes dans des environnements
secure parce que voilà je vais avoir des
peurs et c'est moi tu vois je bidouille
et en programmation jeu je m'y intéresse
beaucoup mais j'ai un niveau très faible
et
j'ai peur de casser des choses mais les
voilà aussi c'est ça c'est s'entraider
surtout ça inquiète
vous êtes combien aujourd'hui
d'associations alors l'association dans
un petit bureau et si tu veux on est
vraiment ou 10 dizaine de membres actifs
après c'est ça qui est intéressante et
c'est toujours c'est souvent le cas dans
des projets c'est que tu as
ceux qui suivent qui regarde qui suivent
de la veille et autres et qui garde
parce que ça les intéresse c'est
peut-être qu'un jour ils vont faire ah
bah oui tiens ça ça m'a servi ou qui
parle tu vois dû beaucoup de bouche à
oreille
après il ya ceux qui sont plus sont
vraiment actifs et qui vont ils vont
faire les projets en tant que tel et
autres et puis je te dis des personnes
qui viennent qui repartent qui selon les
projets qu'on donne donc on est un
on est un petit collectif et c'est
toujours des décisions tu vois il ya
rantisi bon qu'est-ce qu'on devient
qu'est ce qu'on fait comment est ce
qu'on continue et ce qu'on change de nom
ce que change de structure
donc ça c'est des questionnements qui
restent qui reste ouvert et je pense que
c'est c'est chouette toujours dans des
projets de dire voilà quel est
l'objectif commun qu'on a un moment
donné est ce que il est toujours là ce
que cet objectif il
il change un peu est-ce que c'est
toujours la meilleure façon de procéder
pour atteindre ces objectifs ou pas donc
d'avoir aussi 7,7
cette capacité de rebondir de
transformer les choses de modularité qui
me paraît important qui n'est pas
forcément simple
voilà vous avez des deux objectifs suite
de ces discussions
bah la fière maman je te dis c'est ce
projet de traduction avec aussi des
acteurs dont on va voir après jeu mais
il ya un projet un événement peut-être
en février prochain donc après c'est à
discuter tu vois si les choses mais
piste où ce questionnement qui en cours
sur voilà entre le travail associatif
août et bénévoles et un travail que tu
peux faire plus en freelance ou pas une
entreprise et qui se sert aussi
finalement parce que tu es bénévoles
parce que tu connais avec tes reconnu
c'est aussi la question de la visite
limité dans une organisation mais tu vas
pouvoir gagner ta vie toi dans une autre
activité quels sont les liens comment tu
crées des règles par rapport à tout ça
et ça c est on en discutait hier on est
beaucoup de collectifs d'organisations
où on est sur des modes et c'est assez
globale dans la société
tu vois qu'il ya beaucoup plus de
freelance de personnes qui se lancent
d'entrepreneurs donc les une
transformation de réorganisation du
travail qui se font et comment est ce
que tu vas tu accordes tout ça sous
quelle structure juridique économie je
te parlais tout à l'heure des communs
aussi donc il a beaucoup
d'expérimentations qui sont faites
actuellement qui sont intéressantes que
moi je je recommence tout juste à
explorer ce que quand j'étais dans ma
tête j'ai dû vraiment me concentrer sur
un sujet mais mais voilà quand avec ce
côté très fort qu'on a aussi bien dans
lecture publique dans driss et
d'expérimenter d'essayer d'avoir ce côté
un peu itératif qu'on retrouve dans
beaucoup de projets aussi le data
saillantes saucier qui tu vois qui
change des modes d'organisation mais qui
fait qu'on lit terre on essaye en
expérimente on voit si ça marche pas en
chanson au module mais avec cette vision
aussi un peu critique
2 tu vois par exemple de ce que ce qui
est devenu l'économique collaborative où
on pensait au début c'est chouette ah
tiens on va mettre son appartement en
location
on va utiliser une plateforme ça va être
plus simple mais au final on voit que
c'est les gros acteurs d'une nouvelle
économie de la data de l'appeler
formalisation finalement de l'économie
qui se met en place et qui rentre
complètement dans un dans un système
économique donné et qui est pas du tout
dans un système alternatif plus proche
de l'économie sociale et solidaire
donc c'est des choses aussi con je pense
qu'il est qu'on essaie de questionné à
plusieurs avec moi que je questionne
voilà qui font partie de mes réflexions
de recherche avec lewis avec constance
avec la cure pinzi avec d'autres acteurs
et j'ai pas de jets pas de réponse
encore mais ici c'est chouette en tout
cas d'avoir 7 pouces 1 une démarche je
vois un état d'esprit mais moi j'ai
passé
ça te parle de la transition tout donner
pour driss et tu me parler de tourisme
oui alors driss et avec constance donc
de qatar qui est aussi membre de la cure
pindi qui était aussi je faisais partie
d'autres projets par exemple on s'est
rencontré lors d'une formation à piton
aux cris d' on entre cherchant
disciplinaire sur akin saillantes ça
fait pour apprendre le code la
programmation python et et on s'est très
bien entendu elle a un parcours en
littérature à la base puis après s'est
formé en ski approche interdisciplinaire
du web
donc elle a line programmeuse elle et
elle y est là toute cette connaissance
aussi très fier de tout ce qui est l'
approche littéraire de travailler sur
des données complexes de pex tu
d'organiser des bases de données
donc et on a eu des réflexions super sur
relation ces transformations la
recherche sciences humaines et sociales
et donc c'était vraiment une super
rencontre d'échangé tu vois quand on
s'est rencontré il ya quatre ans et on a
monté de ris parce qu'on avait beaucoup
de demandes de formation beaucoup on est
des demandes de formation elle cette
programmation avec cité des vraiment
d'immersion pratique dans dans l'univers
du code et pas forcément être seulement
dans le côté apprentissage du code de la
programmation mais aussi comprendre va
vraiment cet écosystème social 7 change
transformation des méthodologies les
autres donc si c'est comme ça que driss
pour a été a été créé on a cofondé driss
et voilà donc là si ces différentes
petites missions ceci à le faire elle a
développé aussi une plateforme qui est
basée sur dit l'abe pour créer un espace
d'apprentissage aux étudiants donc voilà
c'est juste qu'on propose dans nos
formations
voilà ce que c'est adri c'est aussi une
aventure entrepreneuriale avec moi tout
à fait que ces rebondissements donc
voilà ce qu'on est en train de faire
actuellement mais ce qui est super
intéressant c'est qu'elle a vraiment à
la fois
on se voit comme deux passeuses de l as
et un aspect compréhension très fin et
j'ai appris tellement de choses avec
elle sur comment fonctionne une base de
données le requêtage d'aller vraiment tu
vois derrière les lignes de commande de
voir comment ça fonctionne et ce à sa
grande capacité à expliquer tout ça et
son envie de ou d'ouvrir le capot tu
vois de regarder d'expliquer et et moi
le côté plus un peu comprendre les
questions en sciences sociales ou
d'autres organisations et des dés que
des problématiques globales soit traduit
un projet plus date assaillants ce parce
qu'il ya plein d'étapes de on en parlait
tout à l'heure on peut poser une
question globale mais après le traduire
entre guillemets en langage pour que ça
soit recruté dans une base de données
etc
c'est c'est beaucoup plus complexe donc
c'est tout ce travail de médiation et de
passage voilà qu'on a qu'on a débuté
voilà pour lui c'est bien de commencer
ça vient de commencer on va voir après
on est en discussion là un peu sur sur
les suites à donner à ce projet si ça
reste pour moi un projet à temps plein
ou si je chie je m'oriente vers d'autres
de projets donc c'est des choses qui
sont qui sont en discussion donc voila
mais en tout cas c'est c'est un beau
projet qu on a commencé ensemble et et
voilà on me propose des formations là
par exemple en octobre on va proposer 4
aux doctorants ou chercheurs aussi donc
ok voilà vous avez du mal à vous avez eu
du mal à trouver des clients qui nous
suit corrosion mais au final tu allais
d'aller à les deux aspects parce que moi
par exemple non on a trouvé ben
finalement si on a créé ça aussi parce
que dans la recherche publique il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui sont
intéressés par sa venue au niveau
institut public oui on a de la demande
là
donc aussi non plus non il ya vraiment
une demande qui qui est fait
après si une entreprise c'est long à
mettre en place
donc voilà ça prend du temps aussi
mais pour pour l'instant par constance
est là il a été le travail bien elle a
tout ce qu'il faut savoir
mais voilà sinon on va voir par la suite
ce que ça va donner
qu'est ce qui vous manque vous avez vous
besoin
qu'est-ce qui nous manquerait comment
formuler ça je pense que c'est plutôt un
aussi bas quelque chose d'humain qui est
de connaissances dans l'entrepreneuriat
comment ça fonctionne et c'est chouette
parce qu'on a appris plein de choses
[Musique]
donc cessé d'aider ce père qui sont
différentes et qui moi qui me
questionnent qui me déstabilise aussi
parce que je suis brésilien
c'est aussi un quelque chose de complexe
en tout cas plus pour moi
personnellement de plonger dans
l'entrepreneuriat de et qui pour moi par
exemple qu'est-ce qui manqueraient à ce
que c'est c'est c'est pour ça qu'il ya
beaucoup dans l'entrepreneuriat du coach
des tu vois une compréhension de comment
ça fonctionne etc
voilà peut-être que c'est ça peut-être
que c'est plutôt et je le reconnais moi
ce qui me manquerait c'est peut-être une
confiance au projet vous pas une
confiance en projet mais une confiance
en moi que ça peut que ce que ça
fonctionne et c'est vrai donc c'est
plutôt sûr surtout ça on sait c'est bah
c'est une aventure aussi humaine on va
dire est qu'il ya des et c'est ça qui va
aussi parce que je sais pas si t'as
monte déjà une entreprise ou autre non
non
et voilà c'est beaucoup d'apprentissage
[Musique]
et c'est chouette et doux papa lorsque
je constate c'est comme un rapport aux
vacances et aux écoles plus plus
effrayant le plus excitant par rapport à
quand j'ai commencé ma thèse
[Musique]
moi je pense que voilà c'est plus
personnel
non mais je vais essayer d'être j'essaye
d'être le plus toujours le plus
j'essaye d'être le plus juste possible
aussi bien de mais j'espère que tu vois
surtout ce que j'ai dit par rapport à
expliquer idriss que je sais mon point
de vue est que ça remplace pas les
points de vue des autres
donc ça c'est toujours important pour
moi de 2,2 le rappeler c'est à dire que
j'ai toujours une vision mon propre
point de vue que j'essaye de questionner
mais mais qui c'est pas pour ça que je
dévalorise les points de vue des autres
qui peuvent avoir une autre idée une
vision des choses donc ça c'est vraiment
important pour moi déjà de lui de le
dire parce que voilà dans les projets
comme ça s'est engagé deux personnes
donc je peux pas c'est à dire que c'est
aussi cette idée c'est que j'ai pas
l'autorité tout donné deux c'est comme
ça c'est comme ça voilà moi j'apporte
une idée et d'autres peuvent apporter
d'autres choses ensuite par rapport à ma
thèse
te dirai que j'ai fait cette test parce
que je me posais plein de questions sur
des choses que je ne comprendrais pas en
terme de deux conflits de tension qui
pouvaient qui pouvaient exister et donc
le fait de faire cette découverte des
sciences humaines et sociales même si
j'avais que suivi à des cours du soir ça
a été une plongée une déconstruction mes
propres conceptions la science ouverte
de découvrir d'autres points de vue de
découvrir toute la relativité aussi des
voix des idées et des points de vue et
de ski des conceptions qui sous jacentes
à ces idées des idéologies des idéaux
des imaginaires qui les rendait donc ça
ça a été une sacrée des constructions
pour moi de voir qu'entre ma vision des
choses mais vision de la science y en
avait peut-être d'autres y avait
d'autres choses c'était beaucoup plus
divers donc ça a été un moment assez
complexe de sortir d'une lecture
d'engagement politique très fort que la
thèse m'a amené à j'ai pris beaucoup de
recul pour pouvoir observer comprendre
ne pas ne pas juger aussi et la dent
dans l'après thèse c'est je pense que ça
rejoint jean disputé avec une ancienne
doctorants c'est à la fois le sentiment
un peu de désoeuvrement quantité je sais
pas toi tu as fait une tête aussi mais
quand tu t'es investit énormément dans
un sujet quand je la travaille et tu as
et je vois aussi de 3 c'est un moment
dur de passer du temps à écrire celle ci
ddd choix un peu affaire personnelle de
tu vois tu consacres beaucoup 1 et tu es
pris part ce parce bebek tu es en train
de construire aussi et donc après ça a
été je pense la pré test c'est je pense
le la difficulté et je pense que
beaucoup de chercheurs et j'en discute
avec d'autres personnes qui punissent
une thèse que la voie académique c'est
pas forcément celle qu'on vit
alors il y en a qui disent ça et autres
mais que parce qu'on vend beaucoup
doctorants et qu'il ya peu de postes
après c'est un désagrément est un
écosystème où on se sent à l'aise où il
peut faire des choses mais aussi on a
une certaine stabilité pour vivre et je
pense que c'est fort non on est en train
d on a vraiment ce changement là en tout
cas dans notre tu vois toi tu t'es pas
orienter vers une carrière académique tu
as fais d'autres choses mais il faut les
inventer
il faut les expérimentés c'est autre
chose et et c'est chouette mais c'est
aussi assez effrayant quand quand aussi
une tasse à bas ça fatigue
c'est ce gie épuisant donc qu'est-ce que
tu fais où tu vas je pense qu'il ya ces
moments aussi de doutes de pour moi en
tout cas de reprise groupe de contact
avec tous des projets que j'avais laissé
côté un retour aussi d'un engagement
nourrit de ma thèse et mes études mais
un engagement sur l'open saillantes si
j'ai une vision comme je te disais plus
de une chance ouverte plus en terme de
coproduction qui m'intéresse donc voilà
peut-être le côté effrayant c'est cette
ouverture des possibles et la nécessité
de faire des choix qui sont pas
forcément simple voilà mais ça je te le
dis et c'est pour ça et c'est ça qui est
complexe parce que on dispute à ce
moment tu es aujourd'hui
thual à célia de ses parents de 15 16
juillet 2019 qui qui a défait des
conférences des tadjiks il ya cinq ans
avec un point de vue différent avec des
idées différentes et la cia qui sera
peut-être la dent dans trois ans sera
peut-être très très différentes et c'est
aussi par rapport à toi je crois que tu
l'appelles aussi dans tes vidéos c'est
un cet appel à la bienveillance c'est à
dire qu'il ya un point de vue qu'on a un
moment donné il faut accepter comme
comment on en parlait tout à l'heure au
niveau de la science ben ça ça bouge si
mouvant et quelque chose voilà quelque
chose qui est une conviction une
certitude aussi un moment
bah puisse changer par des priorités qui
change par des événements des
opportunités c'est la vie mais ça c'est
difficile quand on a une notoriété en
tout cas une notoriété ou parle sur le
web et hot c'est d'accepter que ba
d'accepter la critique d'accepter que ce
qu'on peut dire un moment donné ne va
pas être le cas à un autre moment et je
me souviens j'ai regardé certaines de
tes vidéos et que tu faisais ce truc là
où tu disais la façon dont tu considères
je sais pas tu parlais du président et à
nice mme son point de vue il ya un an
était très différent de 2 voilà ce que
tu as ce que tu as menée maintenant donc
c'est finalement tous ces processus ou
de transparence qui sont hyper
intéressant de deux d'ouvrir le
cheminement de pensée un moment un
moment donné peut-être plus rapidement
que quand tu avais des ouvrages où tu
prenais je ne sais pas tu vois plus en
sciences humaines tu prenais sept ans a
travaillé sur un terme et puis tu
publier quelque chose et puis d'autres
et quand tu prends un auteur aussi ses
sacs en boîte quand tu prends par
exemple michel foucault et ben tu vois
qu'il a évolué dans sa façon de penser
et parfois on a aussi cette vision
catégorique
2 voilà d'une identité et de garder
cette image là alors que voilà ton
identité ce que tu es
2 comment tu penses évolué est tant
mieux mais c'est ça aussi peut-être
connaissiez effrayant entre par le fait
que je je je repars un peu de mes
recherches qui sont peut-être des
recherches que je mène là un moment
donné qui vont évoluer et que j'aurai
peut-être une évolution aussi deux de
mes pensées mais c'est ce côté là de
d'accepter aussi que tes idées peuvent
être pris et là dessus je remercie
énormément ma ma causerie tri de tester
florence piron qui l'entrepôt log
éthicienne à la bad qui a écrit un
article super qui sur la figure de
l'anthropologue comment un anthropologue
et par rapport à son terrain par rapport
à ce qu'il étudie et autres et quand tu
quand tu partage des savoirs il faut
savoir aussi que c'est savoir ils vont
pouvoir être repris mais très approprié
que c'est savoir aussi ça peut donner
des billes et des moyens d'action à des
personnes mais c'est ça c'est ça aussi
c'est que quand tu vois tu vois il ya
des interviews de tshing kimberley sur
le web entre ce qu'il a voulu faire au
début est ce que c'est maintenant il se
dit oulala mince où ça a été mais c'est
ça aussi c'est 6 émouvant si complexe et
je pense que c'est cette acceptation de
pas savoir de ce que ça va donner aussi
mes deux voilà donc c'est un peu flou
que je suis désolé c'est peut-être plus
des réflexions et des pincettes que
j'essaye de prendre pour pour pour
blesser personne dans dans ce que je dis
et de rappeler toutes là toute la
petitesse en tout cas de ce que j'ai de
voilà de l'humilité que j'essaye de dire
que je suis bien loin de je veux pas
avoir un temps qui autoritaire
dogmatique je partage juste que j'essaye
de comprendre sur le monde un moment t
de ce que j'essaye de vivre aussi avec
toutes les têtes les erreurs ou des
rebondissements et c'est quelque chose
qui est important pour moi de faire
passer en tête tu parler du fait que
après la thèse ça ferait cesser
c'est l'aboutissement d'un truc et ça
peut être difficile après que non mais
c'est pas tout à fait j'ai enchaîné
directement avec un post-doc mais quand
j'ai fini mon post doc et que je me suis
lancé sur youtube
c'est une période difficile que c'est
l'incertitude comme inconnu
c'est pas facile de rebondir de changer
de nom de domaine comme ça et là dessus
pas tu vois ces essais constance qui a
trouvé ce nom là c'est bien dans ta
thèse déjà la thèse moi c'est quelque
chose qui j'avais proposé un projet qui
est en ligne sur nos dos aux cris sans
de recherche interdisciplinaire sur
l'accompagnement des doctorants pour
question est ce que c'est que le
un être un doctorat et mettre en place
des cours donc tout un protocole de
recherche en co design là dessus qu'on
n'a pas été acceptée voilà c'est aussi
comme ça mais en tout cas je les ai mis
en ligne comme ça je me dis que
peut-être qu'un jour ça servira mais
c'est le doctorat c'est pas simple et
c'est pour ça qu'elles eurent pillé 10 à
ses nerfs aussi c'est pour tous côtés
qu'est ce qui est compliqué pourquoi
c'est compliqué se sentir un peu moins
seul et oui la pré test et c'est aussi
complexe et je pense que surtout dans
cette cité un peu plus de l'association
à l'encré des savoirs pas oublier que
c'est moi je le vois et alors après
c'est toujours un point de vue et
peut-être mais je serais heureuse
d'avoir d'autres deux points de vue tu
vois d'en discuter plus collectivement
de de cette fatigue après après la thèse
d'une fatigue qui est à la fois mental
je pense mais aussi physique un
épuisement et chacun réagit différemment
mais il ya vraiment ce temps de
décompression au final je pense
et tant mieux s'il y en a qui ne l'ont
pas mais voilà deux et je me souviens
j'avais discuté avec une bibliothèque et
un événement c'est le sentiment de
désoeuvrement de l'effort et de dire
qu'est ce qu'on fait après comment le
fait avec des enjeux aussi financiers
qui sont qu'ils soient importants de est
vraiment 7
comment est-ce qu'on passe on pense le
poste pèse pas seulement le poste de
post doc
mais la prothèse et il ya plein de et là
tu y as plein d'accompagnement qui sont
faits je sais qu'il ya des associations
qui travaille beaucoup là-dessus
accompagné en termes économiques ces
doctorants mettre en valeur toutes leurs
compétences associées dans d'autres
faire donc il ya plein de choses qui
sont faits de par des doctorants qui se
sont rendus compte que c'était complexe
après voilà donc mais ça m'a fait
quelque chose
baky qui seraient intéressés seraient
intéressés d'avoir des retours et comme
je te dis de comment est ce qu'on
construit ça d'avoir des retours de
point de vue
ah voilà sur les feintes de passe
d'armes aussi parce que comment est ce
qu'on continue faire la recherche nepad
est dans des postes de classiques c'est
je pense il ya plein de choses à tester
mais c'est c'est à expérimenter c'est
pas toujours c'est pareil mais là c'est
plus le côté l'incertitude s'est jamais
simple à vivre
l es tu le disais peut-être avec youtube
ça a été des fois que tu as fait il ya
des moments où on arrive à les faire
donc moment où on a besoin dans
l'incertitude et trop stressants donc
c'est comment est-ce qu'on gère tout ça
et c'est ces humains avant tout quoi
puis une histoire aussi de
questionnements existentiels
potentiellement qui est difficile
j'étais trop grimper sur le podium quand
ce que tu vois l'évolution du vin quand
est ce que le peuple conson ça a évolué
au cours des années me direz comment ce
que tu as le futur de punchlines alors
comment ça évolue et déjà on parlait
beaucoup d' open access au départ
traduit par libre accès accès ouvert ce
qu'on a eu vraiment c'est tu peux aller
sur le site
il ya eu six français maintenant que les
ti mise en place par le comité la
science ouverte qui s'appelle le coso
qui a un site qui s'appelle science
ouverte qui reprend un peu l'histoire
d'émulation verte
l'open access mais voilà ça a été déjà
un mouvement au sein des milieux bata
recherche comme tu disais de concept
easy c'est pas normal qu'on puisse pas
publiés donc des chercheurs des
bibliothécaires qui se sont déjà qu'on
déjà expérimenter des choses tu vois par
exemple arxiv après il ya une clause
plus tard qui s'est mise en place donc
il ya des plateformes qui se sont
développées place c'est un journal
complètement d'aucun accès ce qui a été
créé après il ya eu aussi les financeurs
qui se sont qui sont mêlés au
schmilblick
donc il ya eu aussi aux prises en
considération notamment pause on a
discuté des enjeux économiques de tout
ça par la montée du numérique
tu vois une époque on parlait de
sciences 2.0 maintenant sur 2.0 un truc
mais ça swingue aujourd'hui on parle on
parle on parle plateforme dans
pendant quinze ans plate forme ça va
être aussi ça sera plus à la mode donc
il ya aussi tout ce jeu de mode qui est
intéressant à voir mais voilà beaucoup
au début on parlait des articles ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'il ya eu à la
fois un peu ce mode copier coller des
articles et des modèles classiques des
revues dans le monde numérique et à la
fois des choses nouvelles qui ont été
inventés des alternatives nouvelle donc
une façon de repenser la publication
scientifique et c'est toujours des
choses en cours chouette en termes de
création tourner dans des termes non pas
seulement d'édition mais
d'éditorialisation aussi d'un contenu
donc ça c'est des recherches en sciences
humaines aussi ils sont là sciences
humaines et sociales qui sont assez
passionnante
donc voilà quelque chose qui à la fois
des quelque chose très engagé en lien
avec d'autres mouvements de l'opendata
de l'open gov qui se sont mises en place
et à la fois nous prive ainsi
considération institutionnels qui ont
fait qu'il ya des mesures qui ont été
prises sur l'eau pétillante très forte à
partir de 2016 avec l'europe la
commission européenne notamment qui a
dit voilà il fallait openskies open to
the world open innovation
c'était carlo schmid a donc des
directions aussi très très forte au
niveau financier qui en fait que voilà
si tu as de l'argent du goût est
institutionnel un projet européen
tu dois être maître en open access même
y avait des projets pilotes sur
l'opendata avec tout ce qu'on appelle
data management de pelade qui l' a été
finalement qui est plus en plus adoptée
dans plein de pays et notamment en
france pour le financement et leur donc
ça c'est des évolutions 1-1 cours et est
ce que je vois donc c'est vraiment une
prise en considération déjà d'un énorme
domaine qui est celui à la fois de la
mise en oeuvre de l'open access des
modèles à développer des modèles
économiques avec qui comment on fait des
luttes par exemple à l'échelle
internationale et le plan est ce qui est
pur aussi coordonné homogénéiser tout ça
et c'est tjrs à un sacré bordel
parce que tu as des projets avec
qui sont allés chalet c'est ça qui se
perd un formidable invitation si
vraiment les projets mondiaux et comment
est-ce que jeffrey pour coordonner tout
ça c'est vraiment un exemple de
magnifiques de coordination nécessaire
mais avec tout leur mondialisation
nécessaire de structuration qui fait
qu'il ya des choix et des groupes de
travail beaucoup d'acteurs qui
réfléchissent ensemble mais qui fait
qu'au 6 et complexe ça nécessite de
faire des choix de mettre en avant des
priorités là par exemple sur la science
ouverte actuellement les priorités c'est
vraiment sur quel infrastructures on met
en place aussi pour les données il ya
énormément de recherches qui sont faites
sur les formes les formats ouverts sur
l'interopérabilité
donc c'est vraiment très précis très
techniques sur quel protocole on est en
place
comment mais c'est ça aussi internet et
le web des protocoles derrière donc ça
montre la russie un travail ce travail
en commun nécessaire par des organismes
collectif pour prendre des décisions qui
sont des décisions collectives qui
change aussi dans les modes
d'organisation mais qui sont hypra
complexe et donc la science ouverte en
ait beaucoup actuellement sur cette peut
aller voir sur le plan national de la
science ouverte qui était mis en place
par exemple en france avec cet axe de
management des données d'ouverture aussi
il faudrait que tu revois les trois 3
axes je les ai plus en tête mais des
groupes de travail qui fonctionnent
ensemble mais c'est une science ouverte
qui reste pour pour moi après c'est
ainsi une analyse que je fais est
peut-être que d'autres ont un point de
vue qui reste beaucoup avec comme je
disais cette idée de sciences
réapproprier c'est à dire que de ces les
milieux de la recherche de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche qui gère ces transformations
et cette ouverture da science mais en
termes de comment est ce qu'on prend les
décisions et de mode de gouvernance même
pour décider du futur de la science et
la recherche
ça ça reste quelque chose très dans
trets dans les milieux institutionnels
et peut-être cet aspect que moi
j'appelle plus tu vois de co production
des savoirs de prise en considération
savoir et autres sont peut-être moins
dans les priorités mais ou moins haut de
l'agenda face aux autres priorités
et donc c'est pas nous c'est pas une
critique mais en tout cas peut-être le
point de vue de laquelle je me
positionne actuellement et avec d'autres
c'est faire entendre ce point de vue la
con qu'il disparaisse pas associée à des
dynamiques collectives contributive
autre chose qui sont des rapports
complexes par exemple sur comment tu
rétribue des communautés qui travaillent
ensemble bénévolement
mais quand deux ans de vivre quel est le
rapport et ça c'est des choses pendant
qu on questionne j'ai pas de réponse
mais avec d'autres qu'avec la paillasse
avec deux projets en avez fait et puis
des mieux sommes ici le réseau français
des fab lab on avait fait une table
ronde là dessus sur voilà qu'à la quelle
bonne pratique on doit mettre en place
entre les instituts les maker les
hackers pour que ça se fasse en bonne
entente et au respect de chacun donc ça
on est vraiment je vois des changements
organisationnels qui sont ici sont
profonds et qui font l'objet par exemple
moi j'ai un ami qui a fait une thèse là
dessus sur les hacker space le réseau
français des fables qui questionne fille
organisationnellement les modèles les
infrastructures juridique économique
donc on est dans tout ça donc je te dis
que je te dirais que c'est voilà de plus
en plus un sujet qui est médiatiquement
fort en ce moment
ensuite l'open saillantes va sûrement
être remplacés dans quelques années par
un autre mot clé est ce qu'on appelle
une parce que moi j'ai appris une
formule c'est qu'à une époque donnée et
à des démos parle à tout le monde et qui
vont quitter reflète-t-il c'est comme ça
que j'aime à un peu un de mes fils dans
ma thèse est un concept en linguistique
à la base est utilisé en sciences de
l'information et la communication
donc voilà un mot qui est utilisé et qui
qui n'a pas une définition entre
guillemets stable mais et voilà sa
rivale est aussi plein d'enjeux donc
peut-être plus tard ça va être d'autres
sens je pense que là on est beaucoup
dans les enjeux de de batum on a discuté
pour tout ce qui est cognitifs
cette reprise de contrôle aussi tu vois
tu vas t'appeler
l'idée de souveraineté algorithmique de
reprise aussi par les états part à ces
partis gaffard par ces grandes
puissances de mettre des freins de de ne
pas aller dans deux dans un
ultralibéralisme aussi donc plus toutes
les envies de données personnelles donc
on est parti là dedans pour pour
longtemps plus actuellement tout ce qui
qui se rajoutent deux des problématiques
écologiques de ya plein de choses on est
là après qu'est ce que ça va donner dans
quelques années
moi ce que je vois à la juste dans les
années très très proche c'est toute
cette idée du co design de
l'apprentissage par le jeu qui se met
depuis dans de plus en place qui est
très présent donc des changements
organisationnels nécessaires à compagnie
et on est là dedans mais aussi pour des
gros groupes des gros pas seulement le
monde de la recherche
je pense qu'aussi peu tous les tout ce
qui est réflexion actuelle et débats sur
ce qu'on appelle l'intelligence
artificielle qui intervint kaki ancien
et très ancien mais voilà qui remis au
goût du jour qui est qui traiter aussi
médiatiquement
voilà on est en plein dedans qu'est ce
qui va en sortir
comment on va revenir dessus par exemple
tu vois des mots que j'ai suivi
l'évolution où on parlait des mots que
toujours ce côté ce qu'on appelle un peu
techno déterministe c'est que les
technologies vont sauver le monde
donc il ya souvent des grilles medias
cette vision des choses alors que c'est
plus complexe
donc voilà il ya des modes qu'elles sont
quelles sont les prochaines mode blog
shane c'est un peu passé on est à fond
dans tes gens sacrificielle dans co
design semble utile dans le design
thinking dans la partie danse des
serious games tout ce qui est aussi
émotionnel
on est bien sûr dans ses thématiques de
changement de deux conceptions
changement de comportement en termes
écologiques et autres donc voilà donc en
se situe actuellement berckois sa part
pense que c'est ce qui me fait le plus
peur c'est des reprises et
et des scénarios dystopique qui sont
ceux du d'inégalités très fortes en
termes d'accès aux connaissances mais de
ce qu'on a discuté aussi de de liberté
cognitives qu'on va avoir des espaces de
création
donc il va avoir des mouvements des
contres mouvement des des choses qui
étaient considérés c'est toujours comme
ça des contre-cultures qui deviennent
les cultures dominantes qui sont rares
il ya deux alternatives qui se met en
place
donc voilà en tout cas je pense qu'il
faut être
il faut être prudent surtout ça alors
après moi j'ai jamais été douée pour
dire il faut faire comme ça c'est comme
ça qu'il faut faire parce que c'est pas
mon point de vue mais c'est plutôt
essayer d'amener une réflexion critique
et partir de l'idée que cg pas la
solution et que ça se construit
collectivement et que ce qui est
chouette c'est de créer les conditions
pour pouvoir en discuter
voilà j'avais posé la question mais quel
message clé tu aimerais que les éditeurs
retiennent voilà je pense que je les les
voilà que le message un message c'est
que voilà gardé beaucoup d'humilité
c'est que quand je parle pas ça pendant
deux heures ou comme hier on a fait une
réunion je me sens toujours coupable
d'avoir trop parlé
ce que j'aimerais que que pas que sheen
a tellement d'autres personnes a écouté
à faire entendre et par rapport à c'est
pour ça que pour dire encore que je
ferai rien sans toutes les personnes qui
sont qui sont là et à faire des choses
et et voilà donc juste les justes hier
que tout ça c'est de façon collective
est chouette avec avec beaucoup de
respect de bienveillant fournissez de
faire les choses donc c'est plutôt à un
message de remercier tout ceux qui
rendent possible tout ce à quoi je pense
je sais ce que tu vas finir avec presque
soit donné quelques recommandations de
vidéos podcasts livres personnes à
suivre
ouais devant autour de tissu alors en ce
moment et je vois très bien aussi dans
le commandant une petite bulle dans
lequel on en discutait avec constance
matin je suis une grande fan d'alain
damasio je souhaites tu connais à un
auteur de science fiction qu'elle vient
de sortir un livre qui s'appelle et
furtif dont qui permet finalement
d'aborder avec avec un point de vue
politique et engagé très très fort mais
qui permet de comprendre aussi cette
croyance en eaux vives en cette idée de
fluidité des risques aussi en lien avec
ba tout un système par une économie de
l'attention sur les traces j'ai juste de
commencer son livre donc les furtifs
j'ai lu ces deux autres livres
après la thèse parce que je qu il
recommencer à l'une des romans donc
j'aime beaucoup aussi par l'aspect
poétique
voilà l'aspect de la création c'est à
dire que je pense il s'était aussi ce
que j'ai dit dans une conférence
récemment c'est l'importance il ya
quelque chose qui se développe aussi en
design tout ce qui est design fiction
l'importance de la littérature et en
trouve beaucoup ça dans des des penseurs
des personnes engagées de de se
retrouver dans des formats hybride entre
littérature entre d'autres choses pour
faire passer des émotions des messages
puisqu'on est aussi on se rend compte de
l'importance du d'émotionnel du
storytelling donc voilà s'ouvrir à des
romans alain damasio j'aime j'aime
beaucoup
après c'est un style particulier c'est
des gros pavé donc on rentre dedans ou
rendent pas donc il ya des podcasts
intéressant là dessus moi qu'est ce que
j'écoute
qu'est-ce qui dot libre après mons et
des puces dont des livres des livres de
chevet par exemple mais c'est très très
sciences positives
une action mais l'inscription corps pour
elle de l'esprit qui est un livre de
varela que j'aime beaucoup et qui m'a
fait découvrir j'ai eu beaucoup de
chance de le découvrir par guillaume
ma caisse qui m'a nourri d'autres en
termes de podcasts alors moi je suis et
tu leur fuite et parce que j'avais
tweets et guillaume labbé tweets et j'ai
vu qu'il avait recruté c'était à les
cours du collège de france avec je crois
que c'est gérard berry son cours sur son
sacre en france à sa conférence de
clôture sur informatique et que j'avais
beaucoup apprécié sur cette idée un peu
de de pataphysique de shadocks de mais
aussi de joie
tu vois de curiosité donc c'est vrai que
moi le collège de france j'aime beaucoup
leur conférence parce que l'on a la
chance d'avoir ce collège de france est
vraiment cette idée d'ouvrir les savoirs
et je voyais là j'ai l'impression mais
compter du 30 mai d'une générosité dans
dans cette volonté tu vois de partage
des personnes qui transmettent donc sage
et je suis beaucoup des podcasts après
je suis plus sûr des choses et il faut
encore que je creuse mais engagée sur la
place des femmes aussi on parle beaucoup
du roi de la g suivie une émission
c'était un podcast sur qu'est ce que
c'est qu'être un bonhomme donc donc
plutôt questionner des hommes sur leur
masculinité sur toute la question de la
masculinité et c'était un artiste que
j'aime beaucoup ce qui s'appelle flavien
berger qui a un qui a un musicien donc
voilà sur moi j'écoute beaucoup les
initiants tueur sur france inter
[Musique]
généralement j'aime bien aussi les
émissions de l'été donc je suis beaucoup
bercé par la radio et je crois qu'on en
avait discuté il ya la première fois
qu'on s'est parlé sur la radio qui
permet de donner une ambiance
particulière de se laisser bercer par la
voix des personnes sur des sujets donc
je te dis moi je j'aime bien
l'application là que m'a fait découvrir
un ami qui s'appelle fabien podcast
addict qui permet voilà donc j'aime bien
ça qu'est-ce qui a d'autres que je
pourrai partager non moi je te dis je
suis beaucoup de conférences le damasio
pour comprendre un peu son point de vue
je t'ai dit aussi qu'un jour j'aimerais
bien discuter avec toi de ta vision du
bail et ziani sme
2 donc de passer plus en mode inverse de
l'interview voilà après ben moi je me
nourris beaucoup aussi de deux
philosophies du raj yoga donc aussi des
visions de 2 comment d'autres cultures
et d'autres traditions de pensée
voyez le cerveau l'esprit est de faire
des liens avec la psychologie actuelle
donc ça c'est des choses pas mal
d'articles là dessus voilà mais j'essaye
surtout et je pense aux salines après
test de garde et de replonger dans des
romans
j'en ai vu pas mal je n'avais pas
préparé
donc je peux pas te voilà je ne sais pas
si ça répond à ta question
mais voilà piocher un peu et essayait
toujours de se questionner quant on y
sur youtube sur ses recommandations et
comment est-ce qu'on peut essayer de
pioche est quelque chose qui sort
complètement maintenant parce que sinon
les paris sur twitter on est de plus en
plus sur des et ça j'ai vu vraiment
changement c'est à dire que twitter au
début tu n'avais pas des recommandations
de ce que un ami a aimé ou pas du bois
donc là on se retrouve vraiment à ce
renforcement des bulles et est ce que
cherche toujours c'est comment est ce
que je peux amener à un certain à une
certaine situation qu une question d
kimm sortes de mets zone de droit de
tout ce que je t'apporte comme vision
que j'ai maintenant que j'ai construite
moment comment des choses peuvent me
déstabiliser et ça je pense que il ya
les voyages aussi qu'ils peuvent
apporter beaucoup
comme tu dis de par exemple un point qui
est très important et c'est important
d'en parler tout la vision de la science
ouverte que des formes à caudry tri de
test et beaucoup avec l'afrique
l'afrique francophone sur la
décolonisation des savoirs sur sur une
autre vision de la science sur une
science qui est pas seulement la science
et les sciences occidentales mais la
reconnaissance de notre savoir c'est
passionnant et j'ai pas eu le temps d'
assez creuse est né voilà ça me paraît
important aussi de s'ouvrir à d'autres
cultures de voir aussi les aspects
hégémonique
on a en occident et qui gagnent un peu
tout donc voilà ça ça me paraît
important des voyages qu'on peut faire
aussi bien un voyage intérieur que
voyage et et partage
voilà super merci pour cette liste de
recommandations de choses à découvrir
je pense qu'il ya d'autres choses à
rajouter un an et puis les 17h51 je vais
donner mon cours de yoga dans au prix
dans neuf minutes
donc il va falloir que je travaille je
classe mais merci en tout cas j'espère
que ou d'avoir engagé cet échange dame
avoir proposé cet échange espère que en
tout cas que ça coûte wassat a appris
des choses ça pourra ça pourra donner
certaines idées voilà en tout cas merci
pour ce temps là et merci pour cette
sphère discussions et puis presse
éditeur je vous remercie d'avoir un
suivi et une prochaine fois probablement
pas très vite